Almost all cross-testing to kill or pacify
SCP – 682 had failed miserably.
If you haven’t seen it, go watch our video
on the legendary Hard To Kill Reptile, to
see just how powerful and terrifying this
creature is.
It faced the Gate Guardian, an SCP with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun – capable
of tearing your atoms to shreds – and came
out fine.
In its face-off with the horrifying SCP – 096,
also known as the Shy Guy, it broke the Shy
Guy’s mind and reduced it to gibbering despair.
Even SCPs with supposedly unlimited powers
simply refused to engage the beast in combat.
So, when it was proposed that they test 682
with SCP – 999, a creature known among Foundation
staff as “The Tickle Monster,” the idea
was considered laughable.
682 had been burned,
suffocated, cut up, incinerated,
and growled in the faces of Gods.
How could this so-called Tickle Monster ever
hope to survive an encounter, let alone win
a fight?
Some even believed that this was the last
we’d see of SCP – 999.
But what makes this story truly remarkable
is that that isn’t how this played out.
As you’ll soon discover, 0SCP – 999 is
an amazing and unique SCP in and of itself,
but its secret origins and its interactions
with some other prominent figures in the SCP
universe are what make this humble, slimy
creature beyond extraordinary.
Prepare yourself for the heartwarming – yes,
you heard that right - the heartwarming story
of SCP – 999.
Several highly-trained agents on 682 detail
placed 999 into the immortal lizard’s cell.
Compared to the giant, reptilian sitting across
from it, 999 wasn’t much to look at – it’s
a large, orange, amorphous blob of anomalous
slime.
Weighing in at around 120 pounds, SCP - 999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity it
was supposed to face.
While its weight has, in the past, caused
minor injuries to some of its human handlers,
it has never caused serious or long-lasting
damage of any kind to a living thing.
Even its diet consists only of candy and sweets,
with a particular preference for M&Ms and
Necco wafers.
It consumes these treats through the cell
membrane of its slimy body, much like an amoeba.
This extremely stretchy membrane means the
creature is highly malleable, including the
ability to stretch and flatten itself out
to a mere two centimeters thick.
At rest, the creature takes a dome-like shape
around two meters wide and one meter in height.
The closest things the creature has to limbs
are prehensile pseudopods, those are the arm-like
projections normally seen on single celled
organisms, of which it has at least three.
The more you hear about this utterly harmless
creature, the more that matching it up with
the pure embodiment of absolute hatred known
as SCP – 682 feels downright cruel.
In absolute contrast to the misanthropic attitudes
of the reptile, 999 loves humans.
It has a playful, dog-like attitude.
Much like an over-excited puppy, when approached,
999 will react with extreme joy and slither
towards the nearest person in order to interact.
It will leap onto them, using two of its three
prehensile pseudopods to hug the person, while
the third nuzzles the person’s face – emitting
high-pitched cooing and
gurgling noises throughout.
The creature is apparently pleasant in every
conceivable fashion, as even its odor has
been reported to smell just like the favourite
scent of whoever is smelling it.
Examples have included chocolate, fresh laundry,
bacon, roses, and Play-Doh.
It's almost impossible to oversell just how
beloved and benevolent this strange creature
is.
It’s one of the rare sapient SCPs to earn
the “Safe” class, and it’s allowed to
roam freely around its facility at all times,
apart from a one hour bedtime period between
8 and 9 PM.
In the rare instances that 999 has caused
harm to a worker at the facility, it immediately
began to back away and contract its body while
whimpering in a kind of dog-like apology.
The closest the Foundation had ever come to
having a real incident with the creature was
the time someone accidentally fed it a can
of caffeinated cola, causing it to become
hyper for an hour before becoming visibly
queasy.
You’ll be relieved to know that it’s since
made a full recovery.
But what would happen when this whimsical
creature is forced to go toe-to-toe with the
Foundation’s most ill-tempered monster?
The employees observing the test watched in
suspense as 999 began to enthusiastically
slither towards 682.
It’s no surprise that after being tortured
and almost killed hundreds of times during
testing, 682 had grown jaded to the cross-tests
it was regularly subjected to.
When it saw this strange, orange blob squelching
across the ground towards it, it sighed and
groaned, expecting the worst.
“What is that?”
the creature asked of its gelatinous guest.
SCP – 999 began jumping up and down in front
of 682 like an excited puppy,
creating a high-pitched
squealing noise.
Just as it regarded all living things, 682
thought the creature bouncing around before
it was disgusting and hardly worth the effort
to destroy.
Was the Foundation even trying anymore?
With a single vicious stomp, 682 flattened
the friendly creature beneath one of its feet.
Observers were prepared to charge in and liberate
999 from under 682’s claws, but then something
truly unexpected happened.
The expression on 682’s acid-eaten face
began to slowly change.
It was beginning... to smile.
Observers recorded a noise that they thought
could have been a chuckle, as the creature
growled and said, “Hmmm?
What is this…I feel… good…”
While the observers looked on, stunned at
what was happening, 999 began to slither and
crawl up from between 682’s toes.
It reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the neck.
There, it began to nuzzle like it had never
nuzzled before.
The results spoke for themselves.
682 was grinning and chuckling, repeating
a phrase that the Foundation never would have
even imagined coming from 682: “Feel…
so… happy.
Happy…happy… happy…”
Just when you thought SCP – 999 couldn’t
possibly be more adorable, you learn about
its greatest power: Bringing joy.
Anyone and anything that comes into contact
with the creature, even in
passing, will experience
a kind of mild euphoria.
As one’s contact with the creature is prolonged,
this overwhelming sense of joy increases,
and continues long after you’re separated
from it.
Prolonged contact has completely cured depression,
anxiety, and PTSD, along with a number of
other conditions, including rage and antisocial
personality disorders.
Serial killers practically become saints after
coming into prolonged contact with 999, and
in that moment, 682 was no exception.
And there truly does appear to be no exceptions.
While “causing happiness and joy” isn’t
a dangerous weapon, when it comes to SCP – 999,
it is an extremely powerful one.
And what’s more, SCP – 999 also appears
to have an innate sense for those who need
its help most – with a particular affection
for the hurt and the unhappy.
The creature appears to be a true altruist
on a fundamental level, even risking its own
safety to help humans during dangerous containment
breaches.
In one dramatic instance, 999 leaped into
the air to block a bullet from making contact
with a member of staff.
As a result, the creature
is pretty much universally
loved by all members of Foundation staff.
It’s the one SCP who never made trouble
for anyone.
Back in SCP – 682’s containment cell,
the beast was still smiling and laughing as
999 rubbed against its neck.
It was an event so strange, so unprecedented
that the observers in attendance felt like
they were hallucinating.
For a few minutes, the monster kept dreamily
repeating the word “happy” but then, suddenly,
the creature began to enter
a fit of uncontrollable,
booming laughter.
It rolled onto its back, slamming its huge
tail against the door.
It’d just fallen victim to one of 999’s
favorite pastimes: Tickle Fights, hence how
it earned its Tickle Monster nickname among
staff.
The tickle fight continued until 682 appeared
to tire and fall asleep, with a smile still
on its face.
After fifteen minutes of inactivity, two D-Class
personnel were commanded to enter and retrieve
SCP – 999 from the containment cell.
They did so successfully, but as soon as 999
was removed, 682 roused from its slumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from its
entire body while laughing maniacally.
It rendered all personnel within a certain
distance incapacitated as they collapsed in
fits of laughter, allowing 682 to escape and
go on a violent rampage.
However, in spite of this, 999 showed no fear,
and helped save some of the bystanders as
security officers subdued and recaptured 682.
And even after all this, 999 showed no hard
feelings towards 682, and indicated a desire
to play again.
It’s a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it’s practically immune
to fear.
Which is all well and good, because the true
enemy that 999 is destined to face is infinitely
more powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be.
What is this monster, and why should 999 have
to face it someday?
The answers to these questions all lie in
the true origins of SCP – 999, available
only to those with level 5 clearance and beyond.
It’s a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places…
There would be no SCP – 999 without SCP
– 231 – 7.
SCP – 231 was a collection of seven girls,
all impregnated by horrific nightmares in
a ritual performed by a cult known as the
Children of the Scarlet King.
Each of these girls, over the years that followed,
gave birth to some of the most horrific monsters
imaginable – one of which, according to
some, was SCP – 682.
These beings were manifested by the Scarlet
King, a powerful interdimensional nightmare
God, believed to be behind a great deal of
the darkness and horror present within our
and many other dimensions.
Foundation higher-ups have declared the Scarlet
King to be the greatest existing threat to
the Multiverse at large, and SCP – 231 was
his latest direct interaction with our universe.
The only surviving member of SCP – 231,
SCP – 231 – 7, gave birth in secret.
But she didn’t give birth to a monster – she
gave birth to SCP – 999, a being of pure
goodness.
That’s right: The nicest, kindest, cuddliest
SCP of all is the direct descendent of a being
that’s essentially the Dark God of all evil.
Feel free to take a moment to absorb that.
The creature even healed the girl who birthed
it, and allowed her to return to normal life
with her family once more.
From its first moments, SCP - 999 was making
positive changes to the world around it.
And according to ancient texts from a Scarlet
King-aligned culture known as the Daevas,
SCP – 999 is still very much in its infancy,
yet it already has the power to pacify its
monstrous siblings like the aforementioned
682.
It’s believed, according to some prophecies
and Foundation theories, that the power of
SCP – 999 will grow exponentially as it
matures.
Why does this matter?
Well, it’s believed by some that one day
999 will grow powerful enough to overthrow
not only its own monstrous siblings, but the
thought-to-be-unstoppable Scarlet King himself.
Not through violence or hate, but through
the pure force of happiness and love burning
out the darkness and purifying the corrupted.
While the humble SCP – 999 rarely outshines
its frightening competitors, to those truly
in the know, 999 is one of the most powerful
and valuable SCPs in existence, and may be
the greatest asset in the Foundation’s arsenal
for the war against dangerous anomalous activity.
After all, what could strike more fear into
their hearts than the knowledge that it might
be love rather than firepower that finally
dethrones the Scarlet King?
And for the knowledge that it may one day
save everything we know from a fate so much
worse than death with nothing but affection
for everyone and everything, it’s worth
offering thanks to the little orange blob,
or at least an extra pack of M&Ms before bedtime.
On March 15th, 2011, Martin Sims was wandering
down the streets of Carson, California.
His clothes were ragged, he was filthy, and
gibbering like a madman with a full beard
and long, unkempt hair.
His body was covered in scars, but he showed
no signs of malnutrition.
What made Martin’s sudden appearance so
remarkable?
He’d been missing for three years.
When he was interviewed by police, they asked
him where he’d been all this time.
They couldn’t believe his answer.
He’d been trapped in an Ikea since 2008.
But this was no ordinary Ikea – this was
a dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as SCP-3008 .
Martin’s strange answers in his interview
were laughed off by his interviewing officers,
who assumed he was either crazy or under the
influence of something, but they caught the
attention of an SCP Foundation Field Agent
embedded in the precinct.
The report was passed up the chain to a local
Site Director, who approved a detachment of
Foundation Field Operatives to look into Martin’s
case.
While he was reluctant to lead the Foundation
Agents back to the offending Ikea – the
Foundation can be extremely persuasive.
His screams of “Please, I’m begging you,
don’t take me back!
Don’t make me go back!” were noted but
ultimately disregarded.
When the SCP Foundation had triangulated the
position of SCP-3008 , which was indeed an
active Ikea, the entire retail zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretence of a severe
black mold infestation.
Armed Foundation Personnel also arrived on
site shortly after, based on Martin’s vague
statements that there were creatures of some
kind inside.
Due to his deteriorating mental health, Martin
was unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of SCP-3008
, but one phrase he kept repeating was “bigger
on the inside.”
Once researchers were satisfied that Martin
had delivered all the pertinent information
he was able to, he was administered Foundation
Amnestics to erase his memory of the last
three years and returned to his family.
A cover story was formulated: Martin had been
kidnapped and abused for three years by a
mentally-unbalanced stalker in downtown Carson.
He’d been able to escape as said stalker
took his own life out of guilt – a suicide
that the Foundation expertly fabricated to
make their cover story airtight.
With the loose end of Martin Sims taken care
of, the true observation of SCP-3008 could
begin.
A base set around the perimeter of the mysterious
Ikea kept a 24-hour watch on the building,
covering all potential entrances and exits.
No exploratory missions had yet been approved
by the Foundation ethics committee, so they
first wanted to perform a week of external
observation to see if any of the store’s
anomalous properties extended beyond the confines
of the building.
After a week of nothing, it appeared they
did not.
A local Site Director approved the use of
twenty disposable Class-D Personnel to explore
the interior of SCP-3008 .
The D-Class operatives would be split into
four squads of five men – Alpha, Bravo,
Charlie, and Delta Squad.
Each would be assigned a different quadrant
of the store, and would deliver information
back to the control team on site via a live
audio and video link.
Three of the four teams, upon entering the
store, reported nothing out of the ordinary.
Neither the audio or video they were sending
back indicated anything different from a standard
Ikea store – from the flat-pack wardrobes
to the Swedish meatballs.
Team Delta, however, suddenly began experiencing
a scrambled audio and video connection.
Shortly after, communication with Team Delta
dropped off entirely.
They disappeared somewhere inside the store,
and haven’t been seen since – with one
notable exception.
After the disappearance of the extraction
of teams, Foundation Researchers classified
SCP-3008 as Euclid, because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the interior
of the store.
And even then, seemingly not the entire interior.
The anomalous area within SCP-3008 became
known as SCP-3008-1, and containment appeared
to be 100% secure.
There was no telling how many people had already
gone missing in the store over the years,
but the disappearances must be stopped.
The Foundation maintained constant surveillance
around the perimeter of SCP-3008 , but it
appeared they could prevent
any further “incidents”
by simply preventing other civilians from
accessing the Ikea store.
Martin’s ravings about monsters were assumed
to just be the product of delirium.
Until a surviving member of Delta Team suddenly
reappeared.
The date was November 3rd, 2011.
It was a cold night, a few hours after what
would have been closing time if the store
were still active and seven months after the
extraction teams had disappeared somewhere
in the confines of SCP-3008.
There had been no anomalous activity outside
the store since the perimeter was first secured,
and Foundation researchers hadn’t expected
that to change, until the last surviving member
of Delta Team came barging out of the store’s
entrance.
Startled Field Operatives were amazed to see
him again, but they were even more amazed
to see what was following him out of the store,
repeating the same phrase: “The store is
now closed, please exit the building.”
Despite the fact that the entity chasing the
Delta Team survivor was wearing the yellow
shirt and blue pants of an Ikea store employee,
the being was definitely not human.
It was around seven feet tall, with no visible
face.
The entity had grossly extended limbs – with
each arm being around five or six feet long,
and ending in a huge, oversized hand.
The whole process was so sudden that the Field
Agents present at the perimeter weren’t
able to save the Delta Team survivor, as the
entity reached forward with its freakishly
long arms, grabbed him, and twisted his head
off like a child with a doll.
The Field Operatives present drew their weapons
and peppered the entity with bullets.
It would later be classified as SCP-3008-2.
The being appeared to collapse and die from
the physical trauma, at which point both it
and the body of the former Delta Team survivor
were taken for an autopsy
by Foundation researchers.
There were no biological abnormalities to
the body of the Delta Team survivor, so it
did not appear that the anomalous properties
of SCP-3008-1 had any effect on the physiology
of its occupants.
He was not malnourished despite being missing
for months, and the contents of his stomach
looked to be half-digested food consistent
with the menu of a typical Ikea store restaurant.
SCP-3008-2, on the other hand, raised a number
of perplexing biological questions.
The autopsy revealed that the creature’s
clothes were actually a part of its body,
like an additional layer of skin.
The creature lacked blood or any kind of vascular
system.
Even stranger, the entity didn’t appear
to have any bones or internal organs, not
even a brain or nervous system.
It was a being made entirely of skin, all
the way to its core.
How it was able to move, or even live for
that matter, remains a mystery.
Though when you work for The SCP Foundation,
you learn to accept that some things will
always remain unexplained.
One thing was certain, though: Martin Sims
was right about his monsters.
After the incident with Delta Team, the Foundation
deemed that sending manned explorations into
the heart of SCP-3008 was too much of a liability,
and planned a series of drone-based reconnaissance
missions into the anomaly.
The first of these drones experienced connection
issues and failed when attempting to venture
into the Ikea’s anomalous zone.
However, after a lengthy period of trial and
error, the Foundation was able to establish
a more secure connection with its drones,
even when deep into the SCP-3008-1 anomalous
zone.
It was only then that some
of the most extraordinary
discoveries were made.
SCP-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of spatial
reality, as the area of the Ikea’s interior
was at least an order of magnitude larger
than its exterior.
Just as Martin Sims had said: It was bigger
on the inside.
But just how much bigger?
The Foundation has yet to find evidence of
any physical terminators within the store
that might indicate SCP-3008-1 has an “end
point.”
While an area of at least ten kilometres squared
has been uncovered in SCP-3008-1, it could
– in theory – be infinite.
Laser rangefinder tests, which are normally
very reliable, have only given inconclusive
results.
Interestingly, the anomalous area doesn’t
have any clear, visual differences from the
rest of the Ikea store except that it extends
forever.
An individual trapped within the confines
of SCP-3008-1 wouldn’t even realize that
they’d entered an anomalous zone until they
tried to locate an exit and leave, at which
point, they’d find they were already hopelessly
lost.
The geography of SCP-3008-1 does at least
appear to be consistent, so people trapped
within are theoretically able to retrace their
steps and escape if they hadn’t already
ventured too deep.
According to data collected during the drone
reconnaissance missions, SCP-3008-2, of which
there appeared to be a vast population, would
wander the stores aimlessly during the day.
They were unresponsive to the drone’s presence,
and did not appear to be aggressive.
While the physical descriptions of these creatures
could vary slightly, they all followed the
same overall trend: “Clothes” consistent
with the Ikea uniform, no face, either seemingly
too tall or too short, and limbs that are
grossly out of proportion with their bodies.
As the Foundation began sending drones deeper
into SCP-3008-1, they found another incredible
discovery.
There was an unknown population of humans
trapped inside the Ikea’s anomalous zone,
and these people had used the Ikea furniture
around them to create entire settlements and
towns within the store.
There were several of these towns, all of
which seemed to cohabitate peacefully.
Even Foundation personnel found this development
in their research to be truly extraordinary.
Since SCP-3008 was first identified, there
have been only fourteen civilian escapes.
Some had been trapped inside for months, others
had been in there for years – some far longer
than Martin’s three-year stint.
While every one of these escapees has eventually
been released back to their home, after a
liberal application of Amnestics and a proper
cover story has been devised, the Foundation
interviewed each of them extensively first.
According to these escapees, the people trapped
inside the Ikea have built an entirely new
society across the various settlements.
Contrary to the “Lord of the Flies” expectations
of a group of people isolated and afraid,
there’s immense cooperation between the
trapped civilians.
The food in the several Ikea restaurants in
SCP-3008-1 mysteriously replenishes while
nobody is there, so there’s no threat of
starving.
And the automatic turning on and off of the
lights forms a kind of rudimentary day and
night cycle.
Night time, however, is when things get dangerous,
as the SCP-3008-2 entities – which are known
to the people inside as “The Staff” – become
extremely hostile after dark.
Aggressive hordes of the
Staff swarm the settlements
at night, repeating “The store is now closed,
please exit the building.”
The civilians inside are usually able to repel
these attacks with minimal casualties, but
the constant war of attrition slowly wears
down those inside.
The bodies of the creatures also need to be
removed from the area after each attack, as
the presence of corpses or even parts of corpses
has been known to heighten the ferocity of
the next night’s attack.
During the day, the Staff return to a docile
and unresponsive state, though they’ll still
defend themselves violently if anyone dares
to attack.
Over the course of the interviews with the
fourteen escapees, Foundation Researchers
were able to answer another
of their key questions:
How had so many people gone missing in the
store for so long without being noticed?
But the answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries.
According to the escapees, there were people
inside the settlements that, despite being
otherwise of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence, seemed to lack very common knowledge
that even a child should know.
For example, some weren’t
aware of the International
Space Station orbiting the earth, or stranger
still, the existence of the Statue of Liberty.
This led the Researchers to a frightening
conclusion: SCP-3008-1 may not only be a nexus
point of multiple Ikea stores in our dimension,
it could be connected to Ikeas in every dimension
where Ikeas exist.
While it only abducts a handful of people
from each store over an extended period of
time, it suddenly becomes clear how this SCP
was able to trap so many people without detection
over such a long period of time.
Which, in turn, led to an even more terrifying
revelation: The SCP Foundation may not have
SCP-3008-1 as contained as they thought.
It might even be tucked away in an Ikea somewhere
near you, just waiting for you to visit.
After all, there’s always room for one more…
When an anomaly is first detected by an SCP
Foundation Field Agent,
it’s up to the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces to tag and bag the impossible
entities before they can do any more harm.
Sometimes these retrievals are uneventful,
other times... not so much - especially when
they’re dealing with brutal forces of nature
like SCP - 096, also known as, The Shy Guy.
A creature that, from its very first interaction
with the Foundation, had a reputation for
being dangerous and needed to be feared.
A series of vague sightings and mysterious
disappearances up in the frosty mountains
of the Yukon first sparked the Foundation’s
interest. When they were certain that they
had an anomaly on their hands, two retrieval
teams - Zulu 9-A and Zulu 9-B - were dispatched
to secure and contain the entity. Zulu 9-A
took the lead in a heavy duty chopper, equipped
with .50 caliber GAU-19 Heavy Machine-Guns
and carrying an AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher. They
were prepared for anything - or so they thought
- as they established a visual on SCP - 096
while two clicks away from the target.
They couldn’t get a clear line of sight
on the creature, but it appeared to be stationary,
docile, and was making no attempt to flee.
Piece of cake, right? Little did they know
that SCP - 096 was just looking away from
them. If it was facing towards them, it’d
be a whole different horror story, as Zulu
9-A were about to find out.
The team landed their helicopter next to the
creature and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked, in spite of the subzero
temperatures all around them. The creature
was unnaturally thin, as though it’d been
starved for weeks, with bone-white skin and
unnaturally long limbs. The team guessed that
the creature’s arms must have been at least
1.5 metres long, but its docile nature and
insubstantial body mass gave the impression
that it wouldn’t prove too difficult to
contain. That is, until they saw its face.
Zulu 9-A’s Captain was the lone survivor
of the incident, as he was lucky enough to
be looking away when the creature turned towards
his team. The rest of the squad ended up staring
eye to eye with SCP - 096, and from that moment
on it wasn’t docile anymore. The creature
began to whimper, then cry,
then sob uncontrollably
in a way that sounded eerily human. This sudden
change in temperament startled the rest of
Zulu 9-A and they opened fire on the creature.
Under the hail of gunfire, SCP - 096 entered
a murderous frenzy and began tearing into
the hapless squad of soldiers. While its flesh
and organs did seem to take damage as a result
of the barrage of .50 caliber rounds from
the helicopter mounted machine guns, its skeletal
structure remained intact and it continued
its onslaught, tearing the team limb from
limb even after they’d blown practically
all the flesh from the creature.
The AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher proved equally
ineffective at stopping SCP - 096 while it
was in attack mode, and it was only after
slaughtering the entire team that it returned
to its docile state. Nobody knows exactly
what the creature did to Zulu 9-A after the
gunfire started, but no trace of the team
was left behind.
Zulu 9-B touched down soon after, and with
a grave warning from the Captain not to look
at the creature’s face, they were finally
able to subdue it. A bag was placed over SCP
- 096’s face, which seemed to soothe it
enough to move it to a nearby Foundation facility.
Little did they know, they’d just obtained
one of the deadliest SCPs of all time, and
while it may have been under lock and key
for now, it seems inevitable that it would
get out and cause more violence and chaos.
Research and containment procedures for the
SCP - 096 were put under the command of Dr.
Dan, a senior researcher at the site. It was
his job to find out exactly what this being
was capable of, and the more he tested, the
more he realized that they were dealing with
something truly terrifying.
Disposable D-Class personnel were used to
figure out exactly what it was that caused
the creature to enter its attack mode. Just
as it had during the initial retrieval mission,
SCP - 096 went berserk when any of the attending
personnel saw its face. In this stage, it
would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable
distress for one to two minutes - covering
its face and wailing loudly. When the period
of distress ended, the creature would mercilessly
slaughter every D-Class that had seen its
face, and just like with Zulu 9-A, no trace
of their bodies would be left behind.
Dr. Dan was horrified and intrigued by this
phenomenon. The creature killed anyone that
saw its face directly, but could the same
be said for indirect depictions of the creature’s
face - such as images and videos? Dr. Dan
was desperate to find out.
More D-Class personnel were brought in to
test this, to frightening results. Dr. Dan
found that the creature did indeed still enter
attack mode when people saw pictures and videos
of SCP - 096’s face. The creature seemed
to have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when it
should have had no conceivable way of knowing.
It didn’t matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the viewer
and the creature, the attack mode would still
activate. And once it did, it seemed as though
nothing could stop the creature from hunting
down the one who saw its face.
With all of this new data, special containment
procedures were devised to keep the creature
safely under lock and key. Its cell was a
5 m x 5 m x 5 m airtight steel cube, fitted
with advanced pressure sensors and laser detectors
to ensure that SCP - 096 remained in its cell
without risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature’s face. All cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden, and
weekly checks for any cracks or holes in the
containment cell were mandatory. Of course,
none of this would stop the creature if anyone
somehow saw its face. In order to solve that
little problem, Dr. Dan would need to continue
his research.
To find a method of subverting the creature’s
deadly glance, they needed to know exactly
what they were dealing with - but how could
they, when even a glance at a photo or video
of the being meant certain death? A potential
solution was proposed - creating an artistic
representation of the creature’s face, something
that hadn’t yet been attempted. But how
would they achieve such a feat? Simple - they’d
procure a D-Class prisoner with some artistic
talent, and they found one who had been a
tattoo artist before becoming a Foundation
guinea pig.
Dr. Dan formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this D-Class alive for long enough to accurately
draw an image of SCP - 096’s face: He would
be placed in a Bathysphere diving bell several
kilometers underwater, and tens of kilometers
away from the containment cell where the SCP
was being held. The D-Class was made to look
at a photograph of the creature’s face,
and then replicate that image in a pencil
sketch. Dr. Dan first
confirmed that the creature’s
attack mode is only activated by the creature’s
face by having the D-Class look at a series
of photos of the SCP’s body parts one by
one, finally finishing with its face. The
D-Class began drawing and even remarked on
how creepy the SCP’s facial features were,
despite not knowing the deadly context.
Meanwhile, back in its containment cell SCP
- 096 sensed someone viewing its face, and
entered its inconsolable crying state followed
by its attack mode. It broke out of containment
easily, and began making a beeline for the
D-Class, traversing the miles between it and
its prey. The D-Class didn’t know it as
he locked the finished drawing into a separate,
autonomous submersible, but he was already
dead. As the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface, SCP - 096 dived
into the water, and started swimming down
towards the artist. Minutes later, the bathysphere
was breached, and the D-Class was torn to
shreds.
SCP - 096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team Foxtrot-303-A, and further
testing on the drawing showed that artistic
representations of SCP - 096’s face were
in fact harmless. From this experience, we
now know that the creature has a gaunt face
with totally white eyes, possibly indicating
blindness, and a grossly
extended jaw. Nevertheless,
Dr. Dan was adamant that SCP - 096 was too
dangerous to be left alive, and requested
permission from the upper echelons of the
Foundation to terminate the creature by any
means necessary. However, the doctor’s request
would fall on deaf ears, until...
It all started with a seemingly innocent image.
(Use this image:
http://scp-wiki.wdfiles.com/local--files/incident-096-1-a/G9zmJ.jpg)
While it’s now been redacted for your safety,
the black spec inside the yellow circle was
once a minuscule image of SCP - 096, taken
unknowingly in the 1990s by a semi-professional
mountaineer. One day, they were looking at
old photographs when his eyes passed over
the tiny spec without even noticing he had
seen anything. But SCP - 096 noticed, and
began entering its attack mode.
It tore through its steel containment unit
like tissue paper, causing the release of
a nerve agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff. The monster then fled the
base and began pursuing its prey, with Mobile
Task Force Tau-1 in hot pursuit. Dr. Oleksei,
who was helping to manage the site where the
SCP was contained, was in dismay over the
situation. Dr. Dan was out of the country
at the time, trying to discover more about
the creature’s origins. However, he did
leave the Mobile Task Force with a new secret
weapon against the rampaging Shy Guy… Project
SCRAMBLE.
SCRAMBLE were state of the art goggles featuring
a new technology created by Dr. Dan, which
- using artistic renditions of 096’s facial
features - could detect and scramble the features
of SCP - 096 into an unrecognizable form,
preventing the normally deadly effect of gazing
upon on its face. In theory, this would allow
MTF Tau-1 to engage safely with 096 once its
prey had been eliminated and bring it back
into containment. But disaster struck on two
fronts. First, the prey in question was located
in a population center, creating the potential
for a huge loss of life.
And the second bigger problem was that the
SCRAMBLE technology didn’t work, as stray
pixels of the creature’s face would reach
the eyes of the task force before the internal
microprocessor had time to scramble them.
The mission turned into a death sentence,
as SCP - 096 slaughtered almost the entire
task force, as well as a number of civilians
in town - including an infant and its entire
family. It was a monumental disaster, made
even worse by a final revelation: Dr. Dan
and Dr. Oleksei had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and allowed
the resulting massacre to happen, with Dr.
Dan hoping it would be enough motivation for
Foundation Command to green-light his research
into destroying the creature.
Anything that would give him the opportunity
to kill this thing would be worth the bloodshed.
His plan worked and the SCP Foundation saw
it his way, approving his request to neutralize
SCP - 096. However, success comes at a cost
for Dr. Dan. Once he figures out a way to
finally kill the creature, though done in
the line of duty, he himself will be terminated
by the Foundation for his crimes against humanity.
But considering how much damage SCP - 096
is capable of causing if it ever got to a
major population center, or - even worse - was
ever caught on camera and broadcast to a worldwide
audience, the doctor himself would likely
deem his own death a justifiable cost. To
this day, the Foundation is researching ways
to kill the creature, and they’re still
looking for their silver bullet. And the pressure
is on. They hadn’t known about the seemingly
innocent picture that sparked the last containment
breach. The one taken decades ago, in which
the Shy Guy had only occupied four tiny pixels.
Four tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost.
So be careful where you look because who knows
how many other photos of the creature are
lurking out there, photos with an innocent
dot in the background. Your eyes glance over
it, not even noticing the little blip, until
you hear a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer, and closer, and closer. And
then... it’s already too late.
“SCP-682 must be destroyed as soon as possible.”
So begins the SCP Foundation file on the dreaded
SCP - 682, a highly-intelligent reptilian
monster that has - despite the Foundation’s
best efforts - proved impossible to kill.
It may not be the most dangerous SCP out there,
considering that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities, but it’s one of the most
iconic, and you’ve probably heard tales
of the monster that death forgot, and you
know exactly why everyone is so afraid of
the so-called “Hard to Kill Reptile”.
It’s been subjected to some of the most
deadly weapons and traps the Foundation could
devise, and survived attacks from some of
its deadliest fellow SCPs.
But before we tell you about the Foundation’s
many failed assassination attempts against
the so-called “Hard to Kill Reptile”,
we need a little more groundwork on what this
creature even is.
The first thing to know about SCP - 682, is
that this thing wants you and everyone you
know dead.
Unlike some other creatures like SCP - 096
and SCP - 173, which are murderous but exhibit
no real higher processing skills, SCP - 682
possesses cunning, advanced reasoning, and
even human-level logical intelligence.
SCP - 682 can engage you in conversation,
but just talking to the creature calmly and
cordially will sometimes cause it to enter
its “rage state” where it becomes even
more dangerous and volatile.
The beast is perpetually kept in a huge tank
of powerful hydrochloric acid, melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its full
potential and going on a rampage.
The creature’s most terrifying asset, and
the reason it’s proven impossible to terminate
thus far, is its incredible adaptability to
any and all external stimuli.
682 is a reactive being, capable of not only
surviving and regenerating from all attacks,
but often incorporating those attacks into
its own wide arsenal.
In other words, if you’re hoping to kill
this thing, you better kill it on the first
hit - cause if you don’t, you better believe
it’s gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder.
This brings us to the main event: Some of
the SCP Foundation’s most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate SCP - 682,
or even understand how it could theoretically
be terminated.
There are quite literally too many unsuccessful
attempts for us to list them all here, so
think of this as a highlight
reel of the Foundation’s
most prominent failures.
682 was first cross-tested with SCP - 017,
a humanoid shadow-entity shown to be able
to consume matter with its shadows and leave
no traces behind.
Tests on tissue samples from 682 showed that
SCP - 017 was able to consume said tissues
with no adverse effects.
However, when SCP - 017 was placed into the
containment chamber with the actual creature,
682 let out a horrific roar that was so loud
it damaged nearby audio equipment.
SCP - 017 fled to the corner of the room,
and 682, in its rage state, attempted to breach
containment.
Agents managed to suppress and remove the
creature, but no meaningful damage was logged.
Attempt failed.
SCP - 173 - the Killer statue - was later
brought in, hoping that its thus-far impeccable
track recording for killing would hold strong.
The second that 173 was introduced into the
testing area, 682 retreated to the far wall
and began screeching intensely.
It was intelligent enough to know what it
was dealing with here.
While the researchers and guards expected
an instantaneous reaction, there was actually
a stalemate for over six hours as 682 stared
at 173 continuously.
Eventually, the tie was broken when Agents
shot out 682’s eyes with high-caliber sniper
rifles, breaking the line of sight and causing
173 to attack.
Though 682 sustained damage to several parts
of its body while its eyes regenerated, the
creature was not killed.
It then regenerated a number of eyes all over
its body, covered in a clear, armoured carapace
that made them resistant to bullets.
The stalemate continued for an additional
twelve hours, as 682 maintained perpetual
eye contact.
173 was eventually removed from the containment
unit, and the mission was aborted.
Attempt failed.
In their desperation, the SCP Foundation resorted
to bringing in another dangerous and seemingly
unkillable monster to take on 682: SCP - 096,
also known as The Shy Guy.
As astute SCP fans will already know, this
being kills anything that sees its face, with
no known exceptions - and when it enters its
attack mode, it’s thought to be quite literally
unstoppable.
Or, at least, it was.
While SCP - 096 was able to destroy 85% of
682’s original body mass during their 27
hour battle, it was left
mentally broken - wounded,
and huddled in the corner.
To this day, if ever confronted with SCP 682,
the Shy Guy reacts in pure terror, turning
away and clawing at his own face.
Attempt failed.
During a deadly containment breach, SCP - 682
also went head to head organically with another
iconic SCP hall-of-famer: SCP - 106, also
known as The Old Man.
The Old Man and a shapeshifting, psionic anomaly
known as SCP - 953 broke into 682’s containment
cell.
The Old Man pulled both of his fellow anomalous
combatants into his pocket dimension to continue
the battle on his terms.
However, despite losing 67% of his body mass
during the ensuing pocket dimension showdown,
682 still prevailed - with the Old Man eventually
fleeing back to his cell, and 953 being collected
and taken away by agents.
Once again, SCP - 682 continued to hold the
title.
But it wasn’t just cross-testing experiments,
intentional or otherwise.
The SCP Foundation’s quest to kill 682 lead
them to a number of more conventional murder
methods, all with varying degrees of success.
Due to SCP - 682’s highly adaptive abilities,
some methods were discounted from the outset.
For example, launching a powerful thermonuclear
missile at the creature was soundly rejected
by O5 Command - on the premise that, if the
creature wasn’t destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes,
humanity would be pretty much done for.
Other ideas were abandoned just for being
too ridiculous - such as one researcher’s
suggestion to fly the creature through the
air and drop it from a considerable height,
hoping to kill it with the high-altitude impact.
I’m not sure we even need to tell you why
that’s a terrible idea.
But, during the experiments on SCP - 682,
the studies ranged from honest to incompetent
to straight-up evil.
One guest researcher fed two small, innocent
children to the creature, just to see what
would happen.
He was then himself fed to the creature for
his sadistic behaviour, which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional conduct.
After all, the Foundation is meant to be cold,
not cruel.
It was SCP - 682 that had the monopoly on
cruelty.
Memetic Kill agents were a resounding failure.
They attempted to dismember 682 with a powerful
laser, only to have the
creature develop reflective
surfaces that displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around it.
They attempted to kill the creature by sucking
all the air out of its containment facility
and creating a vacuum, but it expelled a dangerous
gaseous compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again introduced
into the room.
The Foundation used high-precision blades
to slice SCP - 682 into approximately 12,000
pieces then separated these pieces.
Unsurprisingly by this point, this attempt
also failed.
The 12,000 pieces reformed a short while later
into the fully operational killing machine
we all know and fear.
In one particularly frightening display of
intelligence and adaptability, the Foundation
attempted to kill 682 with extreme heat, but
it shielded itself by developing a secondary
carapace composed of solid helium.
When personnel entered the room following
the failed attempt on the creature’s life,
it shattered its helium carapace into deadly
shards that fired around the room and shredded
all Foundation personnel in attendance.
It’d set a trap, and that trap had been
wildly successful.
The creature’s ability to adapt to seemingly
any offensive is unparalleled, to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how to
classify this creature - whether it’s organic,
inorganic, or even alive at all based on any
definitions we could understand.
At every turn, the creature just raised more
questions.
What is it?
Is it possible to destroy it at all by any
means?
Who was even trying to kill who here?
Because it certainly seemed like SCP - 682
had a masterful K/D ratio by now.
More extreme feats of cross-testing continued
in the Foundation’s growing desperation
to eliminate this monster.
SCP - 162, which is a hypnotic ball of sharp
objects, hooks, and high-tension fishing line,
was introduced to 682’s containment cell.
The hooks latched onto the creature and tore
huge portions off, including its entire lower
jaw and one of its limbs.
However, 682 was still able to breach containment,
kill eleven people, and badly wound 86 others.
It regenerated its severe injuries in no time.
The beast was even taken to the domain of
The Gate Guardian, one of the proposals for
SCP - 001.
The Guardian has a flaming sword hotter than
the sun, capable of destroying its targets
on an atomic level.
Naturally, SCP - 682 survived and regenerated.
Perhaps the most fascinating cross-test of
all was between 682 and SCP - 053, who manifests
as a kind, innocent little
girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal tendencies
in all who come into contact with her for
more than ten minutes.
The people with these tendencies would then
attempt to harm the girl, but would immediately
drop dead shortly after, leaving the girl
intact.
The researchers present anticipated two possible
outcomes here: The optimistic outcome, in
which 682 entered a rage state, attacked 053,
and died for good.
And the realistic outcome, in which 682 attacked
053, possibly experienced some minor injury
or nothing at all, and 053 had to be removed
from the containment cell.
But that didn’t happen.
What did occur was considerably more shocking
than any kind of violence.
When 053 entered 682’s containment chamber,
the monster became uncharacteristically docile.
Researchers and staff were baffled, and watched
with amazement as 053 approached the terrifying,
immortal, mass-murdering monster...and began
to play with it.
682 even allowed 053 to draw on its face with
crayons.
Researchers thought they must’ve been dreaming,
seeing this surreal display play out.
053 even appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope.
It was a single act in defiance of everything
they thought they knew.
When Foundation personnel entered the containment
cell to separate the two, 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards.
053 also wept, sad at being separated from
her new friend.
To this day, despite further testing, the
Foundation has no idea how or why this happened.
Like many details surrounding SCP - 682, it’s
shrouded in deeply frustrating mystery.
And so the tale of SCP - 682 continues, in
spite of the Foundation’s best efforts.
The monster continues to breach containment
and slaughter with some regularity, taking
out its seemingly limitless hatred for not
only human beings, but anything that dares
draw breath.
Nobody knows where exactly the creature is
from, what its true nature is, or why its
ability to adapt and regenerate far exceeds
any known organism on this planet.
Perhaps one day, through enough research and
cross testing, we can someday answer these
questions with scientific precision, but until
then, we only have one answer: Hatred never
dies.
It isn’t easy to work for The SCP Foundation.
Not only is the job dangerous - you could
be eaten by a giant, immortal lizard or
turned into organic furniture inside the
world’s scariest living room - but it’s also
insanely complicated. How do you make sense
of the nonsensical? What’s the definition
of strange when your career is securing,
containing, and protecting anomalous objects
and entities? This brings us to SCP - 001.
Rather than a single object, location, or
being, SCP - 001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential candidates for
the prestigious 001 spot. Some believe there’s a
true 001 hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys, others think that these are all just
SCPs catalogued prior to the introduction
of the current classification system. Some
even think that all of the proposals have
a valid claim to the SCP - 001 throne.
We’re not here to make a final judgement, instead,
we’re going to take you on a lightning-round crash
course through 31 of the SCP - 001 proposals. If
you’d like a more in-depth take on any of
these SCPs, let us know in the comments,
but for now, there’s no more time to
waste. After all, we’ve got a lot to cover.
Let’s go.
Number 31: The Sheaf of Papers. This seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one of the
most mysterious and feared items under
the Foundation’s lock and key. While
it appears to be a simple confidential
report, every time the papers are read,
it details the appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after. The question
is whether the sheaf of papers is warning us
about these entities, or creating them itself.
Number 30: The Prototype. This account details
the capture of an incredibly strange cycloptic
creature that emits massive amounts of
radiation and can create microsingularities.
The writing of this creature’s file is so basic,
unformatted, and unredacted that it’s clear that
the being was one of the earlier creatures
secured by the organization. Interestingly,
it was during the capture of this
creature that Dr. Keter was killed,
inspiring the creation of the
infamous Keter Class in his honor.
Number 29: The Gate Guardian. This huge,
multi-winged, sword-wielding Biblical energy-being
may have been the impetus for the founding of the
SCP Foundation. This being remains largely static,
guarding the intersection of the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers. Its flaming sword,
which is believed to be as hot as the sun,
can cleave any aggressor out of existence at
the atomic level. When the Founder of the SCP
Foundation first encountered the Gate Guardian,
they heard one word echoing through their
mind: PREPARE. And the rest is history.
Number 28: The Lock. This onyx gemstone and the
incredibly complex lock attached to
it are still a mystery. To this day,
all attempts to open have failed. Personally,
we think that’s probably for the best...
Number 27: The Factory. As the name suggests,
this SCP is literally a factory founded by a
pagan and a devil worshipper. While it’s believed
that the factory could create just about anything,
its specialty was creating a number of the
SCPs we know and fear today. Pre-Foundation
Forces were able to disable the factory, but
not without sustaining their own heavy losses.
Number 26: The Spiral Path. This is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that, when travelled
clockwise, appears completely normal. However,
when travelled counter-clockwise, the path
goes uphill forever, in defiance of all laws of
physics. This simple anomaly opened a Pandora’s
box of rampant anomaly creation - leading to
a number of the deadly SCPs we know today.
Number 25: The Legacy. This SCP is a
collection of seemingly random objects,
including a diary from a person claiming
to be from another reality, attempting to
halt a trans-dimensional corruption that
they themselves created. The diary claims
to have a solution to this Corruption,
but the solution has not yet been found.
Number 24: The Database. In one of the strangest
twists on the format, this SCP is actually the
various authors of the SCP Wiki, who are somehow
leaking top-secret information to the public.
Number 23: The Foundation. This
SCP, first discovered by the FBI,
is an anomalous high school building that
experiences shifting internal geometry
and sometimes manifests hostile humanoids within.
Number 22: Thirty-Six. One of the rare benevolent
SCPs, the thirty-six are humans with a truly
remarkable ability - they can dampen or even
neutralize any SCP they come into contact with.
Though it’s implied that the thirty-six may have
the power to save the world, every time one of
them dies, a supernatural calamity occurs,
often leaving hundreds of innocents dead.
Number 21: Keter Duty. This refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
Keter-class SCPs, whose presence around each other
creates a kind of mutually-assured cancellation.
If one of these SCPs breaches containment,
that’s bad news. But if all of them do,
it’ll produce a bubble of reality
distortion that will fundamentally
alter reality as we know it. For all we
know, it may have even happened already...
Number 20: Ouroboros. This is a proposal that’s
formed of four sub-proposals. Remember what
we said about complicated? These sub-proposals
include The Children - nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive potential when
together. The Broken God - aka Mekhane, The god of
metal, intelligence, and machines. Atonement - A
researcher turned into a humanoid singularity with
the power to destroy whole realities. And The Way
It Ends - which isn’t technically an SCP, but the
tales of the Chaos Insurgency’s quest to eliminate
all the members of the Foundation’s O5 Council.
Number 19: A Record. This is an SCP File
slot that is itself an SCP. Whatever is
written in this slot becomes true, and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself
into a kind of all-powerful God.
Number 18: Past and Future. These SCPs
are a collection of powerful entities
that despise humanity, and are apparently
the source of all anomalous phenomena - even
making already dangerous SCPs deadlier
than before. Much like in The Database,
those pesky SCP Wiki writers may
have something to do with this...
Number 17: The Consensus. This SCP refers to
a reality restructuring event caused by an
occult war in a previous reality. That’s right
- this SCP already won, and we’re living in its
new reality. The only people who remember the
world as it once was are thirteen people who
now form the O5 council. And not all of them
are telling the truth about what they know...
Number 16: When Day Breaks. This proposal details
a potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon, wherein
the sun becomes hostile and begins to melt all
living beings into a living wax-like substance.
Number 15: God’s Blind Spot. This is an
anomalous area referred to as Facility T,
in which nobody can die. This anomaly dates
back to the Biblical age of Moses, and is
believed to have originated from the literal
blessing of the Abrahamic God. It’s through
a covenant with this God that the Foundation is
able to make limited use of this death free area.
Number 14: Normalcy. Ever wondered what the
Foundation’s definition of “anomalous” is,
exactly? It all comes from this proposal
- which is a document shared among the O5
council that gives solid definitions to the
fundamental laws of reality. If something
breaks these laws, that’s an anomaly, and
it then becomes the Foundation’s business.
Number 13: The World At Large. As the
title suggests, this SCP is our home
planet Earth and its ability to support
life. It’s believed that these qualities
were planted on Earth in our reality
by another dimension’s SCP Foundation
hoping to continue human life after some
terrible calamity in its own dimension.
Number 12: Dead Men. This SCP was an 84 year
old man whose body, when damaged and mutilated,
can affect the very processes of human
death at large. Before his own death,
he was used as a dangerous pawn in a civil
war between O5 Command and the SCP Foundation
Ethics Committee. Yeah, we were surprised
to hear they had an ethics committee too.
Number 11: The World’s Gone Beautiful. This
SCP describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the apocalypse,
in which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at peace
before their destruction 24 hours later.
Number 10: The Scarlet King. This is an
extremely powerful, extremely malevolent,
extremely extra-dimensional being. Its
worshippers attempted to summon him in
the ritual that created SCP - 231, and
it’s believed that he will finally enter
our reality after the death of SCP - 231 - 7.
You better hope you’re already dead by then.
Number 9: A Simple Toymaker,
aka Dr. Wondertainment. This
is a reality bender who appears to
be a normal human male, but has the
ability to create other anomalous objects -
a number of which are now catalogued SCPs.
Number 8: Story of Your Life. This is another
anomalous document that has the ability to warp
reality, but only when the writing contained
within conforms to narrative structure.
Number 7: A Good Boy. This is another anomalous
entity created accidentally by the Foundation
itself. A neural network was fed information on
other anomalous entities in order to help the
Foundation come up with better containment
and neutralization procedures. Problem was,
the computer got way, way too eager
with the neutralization part...
Number 6: Project Palisade. This is another
anomaly created by the Foundation, this time
to combat a potentially reality-destroying entity
known as The Worm. The Foundation created a number
of alternate realities as shields, but it’s
possible that this just made The Worm stronger.
Number 5: O5 - 13. The final member
of the O5 council who, ironically,
may not even be anomalous. However,
seeing as all the other members of
the O5 council are anomalous, O5 -
13’s lack of anomalous properties is,
therefore, anomalous. Like we told
you earlier, it’s complicated.
Number 4: Fishook. This is less an actual SCP,
and more about the difficult process
of ascertaining the true 001 - if such
a thing is possible. The very concept of SCP
- 001 is, to some degree, an anomalous idea.
Number 3: The Sky Above the Port. Another
particularly bizarre SCP regarding the permanent
threat of a ZK-Class Reality Failure. How is
such a calamitous event prevented? By keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally entertained.
The current proposed solution is keeping the
entity entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file entry.
Number 2: The Solution. Another one of the most
powerful anomalous items in the Foundation’s
control, the Solution is a machine designed with
the capability of fully collapsing reality in the
event of an end-of-the-world SCP containment
breach. And then, fully rebuilding reality to
suit a given narrative. However, things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the machine began
to act on its own. When the Foundation
tried to reboot the machine, it broke,
and recreated reality with incomplete
data. This is the world we exist in now,
with no knowledge of what came before, and how
it differed from the world we experience today.
Finally, Number 1: The Tindalos Trinity. Put
very simply, the Tindalos Trinity represents
three timelines that converge and feed back in on
themselves. Even trying to summarize this one is
near-impossible, as its strangeness and complexity
resists all reduction. You can hunt down the
Tindalos Trinity yourself and hope to unpack
its secrets, but don’t say we didn’t warn you.
So, that’s SCP - 001, all 31 potential proposals.
Is it one of them, all of them, or even none of
them? Perhaps that’s a question best left up
to the Foundation. Or maybe the simple answer
is that you’re just not meant to know - we’re
talking about information so privileged here that
it’s protected by a Memetic Kill Agent that’ll
quite literally make you drop dead if you view
the files without proper authorization.
You do have proper authorization, right?
There are some things human beings aren’t
meant to know, and it’s the sworn duty of
The SCP Foundation to discover and contain
such information.
But sometimes, knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the Foundation itself to its very
core.
One such discovery occurred on April 28th,
2016 – the night that SCP – 2935 made
itself known to Foundation personnel.
To this day, the exact nature of SCP – 2935
is a mystery that even the Foundation’s
brightest minds can’t completely understand.
Everything we know about SCP – 2935 today
comes from three doomed missions into the
anomalous zone’s interior.
This is the story of those infamous expeditions.
The nightmare began around 5:00 AM, when SCP
Foundation Site 81 in Bloomingdale, Indiana,
intercepted a distorted radio signal.
Communications personnel at the site traced
this strange signal back to the unincorporated
area of Joppa, Indiana, near US Interstate
70.
As is Foundation policy, a team of Field Agents
were dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with.
However, rather than finding anything that
could logically produce such a signal, they
instead discovered a long abandoned cemetery.
The most recent death on any of the tombstones
was recorded as being over a hundred years
ago, all the way back in 1908.
On further investigation,
the Foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening beneath
the cemetery and when they sent a drone into
the depths of the cave, it appeared to quickly
exit out the other side of the cave.
But something wasn’t right.
The area that the drone was observing appeared
consistent with the landscape from which it’d
entered, but now it looked somehow…greyer.
It lacked the color and life of the place
it’d just come from.
The grass was dead.
There were no trees, no shrubs, no animals
or birds in the sky.
They weren’t looking at our world.
They were looking at a strange reflection
of our world on the other side of the cave.
In fact, it wasn’t a cave at all – it
was a passageway between two dimensions.
It was SCP – 2935.
Just then they were able to unscramble the
distorted transmission they’d been receiving.
It went as follows:
“This is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and your national
government.
One or more of our sites is experiencing a
communication breakdown,
likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude.
All citizens are ordered to stay in their
homes as containment teams work to secure
the breach.
This message will broadcast from April 20th,
2016 until—”
At that point, the message would cut and repeat,
as it had been for eight straight days.
The message’s source?
Site 81.
But not this Site 81.
The SCP Foundation was receiving an emergency
distress signal from themselves in another
dimension – a bizarre event that even the
Foundation had never experienced before.
The Field Agents were
terrified by the implications
of what they’d just heard and contacted
Site 81 Command to request additional units.
The Foundation wished to fully understand
this anomaly as quickly as possible, due to
the potential threat it could pose towards
the Foundation, so they dispatched Mobile
Task Force Epsilon-13, codenamed “Manifest
Destiny”, to perform the first of three
manned missions into the heart of the anomalous
zone.
The first exploratory mission into SCP – 2935
was codenamed “Gauntlet”, and consisted
of a four-man team fitted with full hazmat
suits and direct video and audio links to
mission command.
The team was led by a Field Operative known
only as Agent Juno.
His subordinates were Agents Kael, Devon,
and Underwood.
Their directive was to gather samples and
survey the area positioned directly around
the insertion point, meaning the other cave
mouth of SCP – 2935.
The mission only lasted about an hour, but
what they saw in there would stay with these
men for the rest of their lives.
After a fifteen-minute trek through the cave,
Manifest Destiny arrived in the mirror dimension
where they were struck by the eerie silence
of a place that seemed identical and yet so
different from their home dimension.
The first observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation.
Trees, grass, weeds, everything – it was
all dead.
On orders from their superiors back in the
original dimension – that we’ll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime – Manifest
Destiny headed deeper into the mirror dimension
of SCP – 2935.
They travelled two kilometers without detecting
a single sign of plant or animal life.
Not even insects.
Eventually, they came upon a farm house with
two cars parked outside.
With authorization from Command, Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed inside.
Agent Kael confirmed that there was still
power flowing to the building, as the lighting
appeared to work just fine, but they came
upon a horrifying discovery in the house’s
dining room: Three adult corpses, two female
and one male, were seated at the table.
A fourth corpse, that of a male child, was
sprawled out on the ground nearby.
If the death of what looked to be an entire
family wasn’t awful enough, the Manifest
Destiny team noticed a number of other alarming
details.
There were no signs of decomposition on the
bodies, nor did there appear to be any obvious
cause of death.
The family’s last meal was still on the
table – Chicken, mashed potatoes, and green
beans.
While the food looked cold and stale, there
was no evidence of rot or spoiling.
The team found an opened newspaper dated April
19th, 2016, illustrating that the family may
have died a full eight days before the discovery.
In Dimension Prime, decay would already be
well underway by that point, yet here, there
wasn’t even a smell.
Instead, everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust.
Command requested that Manifest Destiny collect
samples of the food as well as hair, skin,
and fluids from the corpses for further study.
Small electronics like smart phones were also
taken from the bodies.
Agent Devon turned on the television in the
living room, and found that, while most stations
were now running test signals, the shopping
channel was still live.
Well the feed was live at least.
Both hosts sat in front of the cameras, dead,
but perfectly preserved.
The date on the screen read April 28th, 2016,
suggesting that the times of Dimension Prime
and the Mirror Dimension were exactly the
same.
In fact everything seemed the same, the only
difference between the two dimensions being
that some kind of mysterious apocalyptic event
had occurred in the last eight days in SCP
– 2935’s Mirror Dimension, but exactly
what had happened, or how, remained a mystery.
When Manifest Destiny exited the farm house,
they once again remarked on the lack of all
signs of life around them.
At this point, the team returned to the insertion
point of SCP – 2935, but were instructed
to remain in the Mirror Dimension while additional
units joined them inside.
Manifest Destiny swelled to sixteen members,
with the notable addition of Agent Roy as
the new commanding field officer.
The team split into two groups of eight, and
Agent Roy and his men infiltrated the Mirror
Dimension’s Site 81 while Agent Juno’s
detachment attempted to access the base’s
off-site deep storage servers.
This second expedition was codenamed “Overland”,
and led the Foundation’s Field Agents even
deeper into the terrifying mystery of SCP
– 2935.
Accessing the site was easy for Roy’s detachment.
It seemed there were relatively few cars on
the road at the time of the mysterious Extinction
Event.
In the distance, fires still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to have
just dropped out of the sky.
Agent Roy and his team, like all SCP Foundation
personnel, were fitted with vitals trackers,
and they assumed that the distress signal
that started this whole thing could have been
triggered by the deaths of every member of
the Foundation at once in the Mirror Universe.
Once inside Site 81, they realized that assumption
was probably right.
Going door to door in the administrative wing,
they found the perfectly preserved corpses
of everyone they knew to be stationed there
in Dimension Prime.
People without a doubt were still alive in
their universe.
Samples from the corpses that the Foundation
would later study even confirmed the reason
that the bodies were perfectly preserved:
The corpses had experienced complete and sudden
death on a cellular level, and even the bacteria
that would typically take
part in the decomposition
process had died with it.
In SCP – 2935, death was total and absolute
across all types of life forms.
As Agent Roy’s team ventured further into
the bowels of Site 81, they
made another unsettling
discovery - their own corpses, in roughly
the spots they had been inside Dimension Prime’s
Site 81 eight days prior.
Some of the Foundation’s top scientists,
including the esteemed Dr. Bright, were also
found dead inside the facility.
In an attempt to see just how far this unexplained
phenomenon stretched, Agent Roy’s team decided
to inspect the containment cells – where
they found that all the Mirror Universe SCPs,
including SCP – 2996, were dead.
In his desperation to find some kind of exception
to the Extinction Event, Agent Roy revealed
a terrifying secret to the rest of his team:
SCP – 682, the immortal, misanthropic lizard,
and one of the deadliest creatures known to
the SCP Foundation, was contained at this
very facility, right below them.
Could it have something to do with what was
going on here?
They descended into its containment facility
to discover an even more unsettling truth.
SCP – 682, the unkillable anomaly, floated
dead in its tank Death truly made no exceptions
within SCP – 2935.
Agent Roy’s team left the site and rendezvoused
with Agent Juno’s team to send their research
and back to Dimension Prime using automated
drones.
Both teams remained in the Mirror Dimension
for another manned operation,
codenamed “Nineteen,”
they had no idea it would be their final mission.
As they descended deeper into the facility,
passing more dead SCPs they discovered one
final clue.
Based on the last activity of the Foundation
servers, the event occurred at roughly 3:00
AM.
While underground in SCP – 2935’s Site
81, the team accidentally activated the base’s
on-site nuclear weapon – a failsafe meant
to be detonated in the case of an emergency
containment breach.
Due to the base’s failsafe protocols, every
member of the Manifest Destiny team was locked
and sealed inside Site 81.
They, along with everything else, were incinerated
in the nuclear blast.
Once again, the Mirror Universe inside of
SCP – 2935 was lifeless.
But that isn’t where this ends.
When the automated drones returned out of
the SCP – 2935 cave to the Field Operatives
in Dimension Prime, they were in for their
own horrifying discovery.
None of the footage or information gathered
from SCP – 2935 illuminated how or why the
Extinction Event occurred.
Everyone and everything simply dropped dead
at the exact same moment.
Nobody was aware, nobody was prepared.
Death came suddenly and silently, and none
were spared.
All the Foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the agents
from Manifest Destiny, Agent Keller.
His final message was: “I don't have any
answers.
I don't think there are any.
I'll do this one thing, and hope that fixes
it.
Seal it shut.
You've got to lock it in here with us.
I'm sorry.”
The Foundation were at first confused by this,
until they discovered a final encrypted audio
log buried in the files recovered from the
Mirror Universe’s Site 81.
It was a message from Keller himself, but
not the Keller from Universe Prime.
In this message, Keller described the Foundation
in the Mirror Universe receiving the exact
same distorted transmission that they did
a few days earlier from a cave in Joppa.
When he and the others were dispatched inside,
they discovered the same lifeless, post-Extinction
Event world that was now so familiar to Foundation
Command.
But there was a key difference: This wasn’t
the Mirror Dimension they’d just been studying,
but a third, entirely different dimension.
In his haunting final words, Mirror Dimension
Keller admits that whatever caused the event
in that third dimension – an entity that
Mirror Dimension Keller believed was the spectre
of Death itself – had followed him back
into his world, and history had repeated itself.
SCP – 2935 was the passageway through which
absolute death could pass from dimension to
dimension, and our dimension was the next
in line.
The deaths of Manifest Destiny may have saved
our entire universe, as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to bring
Death itself back with them.
The Foundation decided, in the end, to follow
Keller’s advice.
They sealed the entrance to SCP – 2935 with
concrete, and now keep it under constant watch,
since what waits behind the barrier is an
entity even they have no power to stop if
it ever got through.
After all, it had killed them all before,
or at least another version of them.
What’s one more dimension on the pile?
While it may now just seem like a simple slab
of concrete under an abandoned cemetery, this
is why SCP – 2935 might just be the most
dangerous SCP of all.
The first thing that tipped the Foundation
off to SCP-087’s presence were the reports
of numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus.
There were plenty of rumors about what might
be behind them, but Field Agents suspected
that the true source of the vanishing would
be something beyond civilian imagination.
All anyone knew for sure was that everyone
who had gone missing was last seen in a certain
administrative building on the university
grounds, and that the disappearances only
seemed to happen when the elevator was out.
The campus was soon flooded with Foundation
agents, creating a barrier
around the administrative
building, and the presumed habitat of SCP
- 087.
Nobody else could get in, and hopefully, whatever
was inside couldn’t get out.
One of the Foundation’s lead scientists
was flown in to consult on the investigation.
What could have been behind all those students
disappearing?
The doctor’s preliminary interviews with
university staff who worked in the building
yielded some interesting details: Strange
noises, like banging and even a faint, shrill
crying, would be heard from a door that lead
to a no longer used stairway in Hallway 3B.
Staff in the building had no reason to ever
take these stairs, especially considering
how many of them reported a strange sense
of unease when just standing outside the door.
The only reason someone might take those stairs
is due to…Elevator malfunctions.
In that instant, the doctor had put it all
together.
The staff they interviewed had their memory
wiped with Amnetics – special chemicals
used by the Foundation with the power to delete
human memories.
The Foundation only used them for staff or
civilians who had confirmed contact with an
SCP, and the doctor knew that they had a live
one on their hands.
The staircase.
There was something terribly wrong with that
staircase, and it was the SCP Foundation’s
job to find out what – before it made anybody
else disappear.
This is the story of SCP – 087, otherwise
known as The Endless Staircase, and the three
doomed journeys down into its murky depths.
The doctor was more than eager to begin research
into the staircase, and its frightening, anomalous
properties.
After all, you don’t claw your way up to
being one of the Foundation’s key researchers
without being brave, and perhaps just a little
bit deranged.
As was standard, once a perimeter was secured
around the staircase, the good doctor requested
a selection of D-Class personnel for testing.
For those not in the know, D-Class is the
Foundation’s polite way of saying “cannon
fodder.”
The doctor was sent three D-Class prisoners
for use in his investigation of SCP – 087.
The first, D-8432, was – according to official
documentation on the incident – a “43-year
old male of average build and appearance and
unremarkable psychological background.”
This man once worked for the Foundation in
a more official capacity, but he was given
the often-deadly demotion to D-Class due to
a dangerous mistake handling SCP – 682 that
lead to the deaths of several other agents.
Now, it looked like it would be his turn.
The doctor explained his mission to him: Explore
the staircase, gather data, help us find out
exactly what we’re dealing with here.
If you come back alive, there may even be
a promotion in it for you.
And with that promise, D-8432 was given his
load-out: a 75-watt flood lamp with battery
power capable of lasting 24 hours, an audio
headset, and a handheld camcorder fitted with
a transmission stream.
D-8432 was then pushed through the door in
Hallway 3B, and out onto the staircase.
According to declassified Foundation files
describing the staircase, “SCP-087 is an
unlit platform staircase.
Stairs descend on a 38-degree angle for 13
steps before reaching a semi-circular platform
of approximately 3 meters in diameter.
Descent direction rotates 180 degrees at each
platform.
The design of SCP-087 limits subjects to a
visual range of approximately 1.5 flights.”
But in D-8432’s mind, “unlit” really
didn’t seem like the right word.
He would have chosen “all-consuming darkness.”
Despite carrying a powerful 75-watt lamp,
D-8432 was only capable of partially lighting
the platform he was standing on – and the
illumination only stretched down nine of the
thirteen steps to the next platform.
When D-8432 observed how little help his lamp
was giving him, he was instructed to shine
it out of the doorway into Hallway 3B.
When he did so, the light seemed to shine
far further than it ever could in SCP – 087.
Already, the beginning of anomalous activity
was obvious: Everywhere else, darkness is
just the absence of light.
In SCP – 087, darkness eats light.
It was like a tangible, black mass that only
a certain amount of light could survive, while
the rest just wouldn’t show.
D-8432 swallowed hard over a lump in his throat.
The door to Hallway 3B was closed behind him,
and he was ordered to descend.
Surviving to see that promotion was feeling
unlikely, but it’s not like he had a choice.
If he tried to escape SCP – 087 before he
was permitted, he’d be shot by SCP Foundation
Field Agents on the spot.
So he followed the high-ranking doctor’s
orders and began to descend the steps to the
next platform.
Nothing about the physical makeup of the staircase
itself seemed abnormal – the base and walls
were a very plain, dull concrete, with a metal
handrail.
The only thing that seemed unique about it
so far was the strange light-bending properties.
That was, until he reached the second platform
down and he heard it, a soft, echoing cry.
A child’s cry.
It was shrieks of panic, or maybe even pain,
echoing up from below.
He was asked why he had stopped, and he explained
the crying sound he’d been hearing.
It sounded like it was coming from far down
the stairs, maybe 200 meters below him.
He could just make out the words “please”,
help”, and “down here” coming from the
darkness.
But the team outside the stairwell couldn’t
hear anything, so they asked him to descend
further.
Another platform down, and they could hear
it too, the unmistakable cries of a terrified
child.
“Please”, “help”, and “down here.”
D-8432 was ordered to keep going and only
stop if he noticed changes
to the visual environment
or in the sounds he was hearing.
D-8432, knowing his life was on the line,
had to keep going, and descended another twenty
flights of stairs before stopping to remark
that the sounds of the child hadn’t gotten
any closer.
They still sounded just as far away as when
he’d first heard them.
He was told his observations were noted, and
pressured to continue.
Within half an hour, D-8432 had descended
a full fifty floors, with no sign of a bottom
in sight.
Somehow the volume of the child’s crying
had remained consistent throughout, as if
it was moving away from D-8432 at the same
rate he was descending.
At this point, D-8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy.
The doctor said that this was understandable,
given the circumstances.
He’d been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire time,
and something about the truly bottomless nature
of the staircase, and the ever-elusive crying,
was undeniably eerie.
But things were about to really take a turn
for the worst.
As D-8432 stepped forward towards the next
set of stairs, he froze.
There was something on the platform below
him, barely illuminated by the light of his
75-watt bulb.
It was a face.
Vaguely human in size and shape, but with
a few terrifying differences: it had greyish
skin, and no mouth, nostrils, or pupils.
And yet, D-8432 could feel that this thing
was making eye contact with him.
He couldn’t move, trapped in this thing’s
piercing gaze.
In an instant, the face jerked forwards, suddenly
only about a foot away from D-8432’s face
– eyes staring into his own.
D-8432 screamed and ran, scaling all fifty
flights in an astonishing eighteen minutes,
before charging out into Hallway 3B.
There, he collapsed from the exhaustion and
the fear of what he’d just seen.
Upon reviewing the footage, the strange face
was designated “SCP-087-1.”
Fascinating.
It was time for a second experiment.
The doctor just had to know more.
The second test subject was D-9035, a 28-year-old
male with a history of aggravated assaults
against women.
He was given the same loadout as his predecessor,
except this time with an even more powerful
100-watt bulb.
He was also given 100 small LED lights that
had adhesive backs and a
battery life of approximately
3 weeks, with which they intended to permanently
illuminate SCP – 087.
However, despite the extra wattage of his
bulb, he still couldn’t illuminate beyond
the ninth step.
SCP – 087 wouldn’t allow it.
Having no idea of the horrors that lurked
below him, he descended on the doctor’s
orders, and began fixing the LEDs to walls
of each platform he passed.
The LED always illuminated the landing, but
the light couldn’t pass the first step on
either side.
The flights of stairs themselves would remain
in perpetual darkness.
After the second flight, D-9035 noticed the
same crying D-8432 had heard and became uneasy.
Just like before, as D-9035 descended, the
volume of the crying didn’t seem to increase,
as if for every step he descended, the source
of the crying descended one, too, keeping
them at a constant 200 metres apart.
Still, he was ordered to continue his descent
and the placing of LED’s even as his paranoia
grew.
When he reached the 51s floor, he observed
damage to the wall and steps – sections
appeared to have been smashed to rubble by
an extreme force.
As he descended past the broken step, he only
felt his fear, anxiety, and paranoia grow.
The doctor made a note of the fact that SCP
– 087 seemed to cause instances of anxiety
and terror in its occupants, even before they
encountered SCP – 087 – 1.
As D-9035 reached platform 89 – a full 350
meters under the initial platform – he stopped
dead in his tracks, and saw something staring
up at him from the platform below.
That same terrible, grey face, with those
dead, white eyes.
He was encouraged to stay calm and try to
get better footage of the face, but it charged
for him and D-9035 ran for his life.
He ascended the staircase at a staggering
pace, even passing out from exhaustion and
remaining motionless for 14 minutes half way.
When D-9035 finally gathered the strength
to get up, he scrambled back to Hallway 3B
and fell into a state of catatonia.
He remains unresponsive to all external stimuli
to this day, just staring off into the distance
with a haunted expression.
Almost like he’s still there in the hallway.
The doctor wanted to conduct one more test
before he ordered SCP – 087 shut off from
the world forever, and it was the most terrifying
of all.
The final subject was D-9884, a 23-year-old
woman with a history of depression and the
use of excessive force.
The doctor had hoped that D-9884 would travel
the deepest yet, and so,
he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75 litres
of water, 15 nutrient bars, and 1 thermal
blanket.
As far as the Foundation was concerned, she
was in this for the long haul.
But none of them had any idea quite how right
they were.
When D-9884 entered SCP – 087, all the lights
from the previous expedition had disappeared.
Still, she was ordered to go deeper.
She heard the crying of the mysterious child
– if it was even a child at all – and
again she was ordered to go deeper.
At the 496th landing, even as D-9884 seemed
to slip into a state of mortal terror, once
again she was ordered to go even deeper.
Every moment, he was hoping to get a better
look at the face of SCP – 087 – 1.
And when D-9884 finally broke, and fled back
upstairs, he did.
The face appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her, staring directly into the
camera with its blank eyes – startling even
this veteran of the supernatural.
The face appearing caused D-9884 to panic
and flee, but instead of going back up the
stairs to safety, she went deeper down the
staircase in an attempt to escape it.
Deeper, and deeper, and deeper, until her
video feed cut out.
D-9884 was never seen again.
In the aftermath of the tests, the SCP was
classified as Euclid – it may have been
dangerous, but at least it was easy to contain.
The door to Hallway 3B was replaced with one
made out of reinforced steel,
with an electro-release
lock mechanism.
It has been disguised to resemble a janitorial
closet consistent with the rest of the building.
The lock won’t release unless a classified
number of electrical volts are applied, while
the key is turned counter clockwise.
And after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the door,
staff at the building never again reported
hearing strange noises.
As for the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of SCP
– 087, we may never know.
But one can only assume it isn’t pleasant.
The SCP Foundation does their best to live
up to their famous namesake: They secure and
contain anomalies and monsters from all around
the world - or sometimes even off-world - and
protect the public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose.
However, despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under lock
and key, there are sometimes creatures so
clever, so devious, and so determined to escape
their captivity and wreak havoc on the world,
that even the SCP foundation struggles to
keep them from getting free.
One example is SCP-035, or the Possessive
Mask.
SCP-035 is one of the most dangerous test
subjects in SCP Foundation custody, and its
mere presence at the Foundation has resulted
in untold damage, death, and destruction.
It seems innocent enough, to the untrained
eye.
The mask, which resembles a classic white
porcelain “comedy” mask - though it occasionally
changes its expression to “tragedy” - has
been in existence since at least the 1800s.
In the late 19th century the Foundation discovered
the mask in a sealed crypt beneath an abandoned
home in Venice.
It is unknown how it got there, or how the
Foundation knew to look for it.
If there ever was an
explanation for its discovery,
it has long since been removed or redacted
from the Foundation’s archives.
You’re probably wondering: How can a simple
mask leave multiple seasoned Foundation employees
dead?
Well, like everything at the SCP foundation,
this mask is not what it seems.
There is a reason its classification is “keter”,
a designation that refers to an entity that’s
excessively difficult to contain - and it
couples this difficulty with a pronounced
hostility toward human life, and the ability
to cause widespread destruction in the event
of a containment breach.
These are qualities that the poor unfortunate
souls assigned to guard SCP-035 would come
to understand all too well.
The Possessive Mask is a parasitic entity,
constantly seeking out a host willing to put
it on.
Any human being in the mask’s proximity
experiences a sudden, unexplainable urge to
put it on and once they do, there’s no going
back.
SCP Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask, their brain
waves are replaced with an alternative pattern,
this one coming from the mask, rendering the
host effectively brain dead.
Once the host’s brain function has been
eliminated, the mask takes over, piloting
their body and even speaking through them.
However, the mask can only occupy a host for
a small amount of time before the body begins
to decay and decompose, eventually rotting
away completely, leaving nothing but desiccated
flesh and bones where there once was a person.
SCP-035 is capable of possessing any humanoid
being, whether that’s an actual human being
or a lifeless humanoid shape.
Despite all their research, the SCP Foundation
unknowingly gave the Mask all the tools and
resources it needed to break containment...
and leave a trail of bodies in its wake.
For a time, the mask was given “host privileges,”
meaning that it was purposely allowed to occupy
a host in order to speak with the scientists
studying it.
In order to avoid murky ethical issues, the
host was usually something inanimate like
a mannequin or a statue.
These conditions, however unsettling, allowed
the researchers to carry out interviews with
the consciousness housed inside the mask,
in the hope of beginning to understand it
and its motivations.
However, SCP-035 lost all access to its host
privileges after it almost
pulled off an unprecedented,
shocking, and nearly catastrophic escape attempt.
In its early days at the facility, when it
was still allowed host privileges, it was
contained in a triple locked room and monitored
by several research personnel.
These were experienced researchers who had
been with the Foundation for a minimum of
five years each, an unusually long tenure
in such a dangerous and mentally corrosive
line of work.
These research staff members were thought
to be the most capable of handling interactions
with the mask, and be able to resist its attempts
at manipulation.
Unfortunately, these assumptions were naive,
and seriously underestimated the mask’s
power.
Research on the mask indicates that the mask
is incredibly intelligent
and a skilled manipulator.
It has a photographic memory, intelligence
that would rank in the 99th percentile of
humans, and the ability to incite dramatic
changes in the behavior in people that it
talks to.
One particularly infamous interview, between
the entity and an unnamed
Doctor at the Foundation,
suggested that the mask may even possess
telepathic
abilities.
The mask was able to give details about the
Doctor’s life that no one else was privy
to, including knowledge of an affair that
his wife was having.
Following the interview, the Doctor suffered
a psychotic break and committed suicide just
24 hours later.
The mask is able to use its superior intelligence,
charismatic personality, and mind reading
abilities to get inside the heads of those
it speaks with.
It will pull out any and all psychological
stops to get what it wants, leaving broken
minds and spirits in its wake.
It was really only a matter of time before
it used this skill set to its advantage and
attempted to escape its confinement.
The day of the escape attempt was like any
other.
The research staff, a team of three intelligent,
experienced men, checked into the facility,
measured the conditions of the mask’s containment
unit, and began the process of interviewing
the mask like normal.
Its motions were slow and looked to require
great effort, as its current host was beginning
to degrade beyond use.
The mask was attached to the blank face of
a mannequin, and corrosive black liquid could
be seen oozing from its eye and mouth holes.
This liquid is excreted by
the mask at a near-constant
rate, and is thought to be at least partially
responsible for the accelerated decay of the
host bodies.
In spite of the entity’s unsettling, nightmarish
appearance, it was just another day’s work
for the men assigned to monitor SCP-035, and
so they carried on with their daily routine.
Everything was going according to plan until
one of the men, Dr. Jones, began to behave
erratically.
He demanded that his fellow scientists leave
him alone with the mask for a while, and allow
him to engage in a private conversation with
it.
It is unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were absent,
as the security footage captured has no sound.
However, several minutes into the conversation
in the footage, Dr. Jones can be seen dissolving
into a fit of tears, laying on the ground
and shaking with sobs as the mask dispassionately
watches.
He then climbs onto his knees, begging the
mask for something, before he embraces it.
He holds the mannequin in his arms for five
straight minutes, weeping again, before they
separate.
After this disturbing emotional display, Dr.
Jones brought the other scientists back into
the room with him.
What happened next is still uncertain, but
there are a few things that we know for sure.
The other scientists began to speak with the
mask.
In later interviews, the other scientists
were bordering on incoherent, babbling about
various traumas from their lives.
One repeatedly referred to a drunk driving
accident where a dear friend was killed, and
he was at fault.
Another simply cried out for his mother again
and again.
Whatever the mask said to them, it was enough
to completely destroy their mental health.
After the other two scientists
had been emotionally
devastated by the mask, Dr. Jones escalated
the situation further.
Dr. Jones removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body, and, shocking everyone who
would later review the security footage, placed
it onto his own face.
Once the mask was in place, Dr. Jones went
unnaturally still for several moments, as
his colleagues looked on.
This is where the security footage ends.
At the command of the mask which was now speaking
through Dr. Jones, the other two men switched
off all security cameras monitoring SCP-035’s
containment facility.
The mask, piloting the body of Dr. Jones like
a horrible fleshy puppet, made its way through
the facility, avoiding detection until it
reached the exit doors, where it was finally
stopped by a team of over a dozen security
guards.
Knowing the dangers of touching the mask,
all Foundation employees
involved in the re-containment
of SCP-035 refused to remove it from Dr. Jones’
face.
Instead, he was placed in the locked room
with the mask still on, left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body had
decomposed beyond use.
His body paced back and forth in its cell
for days, flesh rotting and dropping away
until only sinew and bone remained.
Only when the bones began to turn black and
brittle, crumbling apart into dust, did the
body finally stop moving.
His family was notified, the mask was carefully
removed from what was left of his body, and
his remains were destroyed.
The other two scientists involved in the SCP-035
escape attempt were terminated, and their
files destroyed.
After this incident, a few more failed escape
attempts, and the acknowledgement
of the devastation
that could have been caused if the mask had
made its way out into the general population,
SCP-035 lost its host privileges altogether.
Several research staff protested this decision,
insisting that there was more to be learned
from speaking with the entity, and citing
valuable information that it had given about
other SCP’s.
However, the risk was determined to considerably
outweigh the potential reward, and the request
to reinstate 035’s host privileges was denied.
Several staff members went so far as to erupt
into violent outbursts on 035’s behalf,
attacking their superiors who refused to provide
the mask with a new host, clawing at them
with animalistic rage.
Any staff members that submitted a request
to reinstate said privileges were considered
a security threat, and reassigned to a different
SCP or in some cases terminated.
Any staff member who had direct contact with
SCP-035 was also terminated, in order to avoid
the risk of any more staff-aided escape attempts.
The mask is now kept in a hermetically-sealed
glass case, and there is a psychologist on
call to provide assistance to anyone guarding
it, in case of adverse effects on their mental
health from the mask’s presence.
Personnel that work around the mask, even
in its current dormant state, experience frequent
violent outbursts and a higher rate of suicide.
Even without a host, the mask’s corrosive
effects have spread across its containment
facility.
The walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from the
mask, which tests have revealed to be highly
contaminated human blood, that damages the
structural integrity of the walls following
prolonged contact.
This blood has begun to form patterns on the
walls, spelling out words and phrases in Italian,
Latin, Greek, and Sanskrit, as well as depicting
drawings of ritual sacrifice and mutilation.
Staff members also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying, high-pitched laughter
when in proximity to the mask.
Further exposure to the mask results in migraines,
hemorrhaging around the eyes, mouth, and nose,
and an eventual psychotic break.
Between the corrosive substance appearing
on the walls, and the physical and psychological
damage to employees, SCP-035
is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are debates
among staff as to whether the entity can,
in fact, be contained at all.
As soon as possible, SCP-035 will be moved
into a new containment facility, and its previous
cell will be isolated from the rest of the
foundation’s property and destroyed for
the safety of all involved.
We can only hope that the new containment
procedures are more effective than the last
ones, and that this mask never makes its way
into the world again.
If it does, who knows how many lives it will
claim?
In the meantime, if you ever come across a
strange mask and feel a nearly uncontrollable
urge to put it on…ignore the whispered pleas
to just try it, ignore the echoing laugher
and the sensation of something older and more
powerful than you can imagine rummaging through
your deepest, darkest secret thoughts.
Turn around, and run as fast as you can in
the other direction.
You’ll be glad that you did.
Jack was swimming deep underwater, wondering
why he had such a pounding headache when he
suddenly had a terrifying realization.
He had no idea where he was or what he was
doing.
There was a nagging feeling that he must have
a specific reason to be here — you don’t
just end up deep in the ocean with a diving
suit on by chance.
Yet he had no idea what he was supposed to
be doing.
He wasn’t sure he cared, either.
He was more worried about the throbbing pain
in his head and the vision of two eyes staring
at him out of the dark that he couldn’t
get out of his mind.
His heart began to race, as he wondered what
to do and how to get help.
He was in the middle of the ocean and appeared
to be all alone.
He couldn’t see anything in the dark water
except for this weird, gray substance in front
of him.
Maybe he was going to die here, alone.
Without knowing if anyone could even hear
him, he began to speak aloud about how he
was consumed by sickness and that darkness
was all around him.
This is the story of one of the most powerful
and dangerous anomalies yet discovered...
SCP-3000.
Before Jack’s descent into despair, the
SCP Foundation had mandated an exploratory
expedition off the coast of Bangladesh.
After receiving a few strange reports from
locals and fishermen, the foundation suspected
an SCP was lurking in the water and positioned
a few personnel to investigate.
The crew expected danger — or maybe even
death — but what they got instead was far
stranger and more ominous.
All of the men had been verified to be in
sound mental states when the mission set out,
but a few of them reported feeling strange
and uneasy as the submarine descended into
the ocean.
Before long, a veteran agent named Dr. Williams
began to panic in a way that was completely
out of character.
He started sweating profusely, shaking, and
wouldn’t listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer.
It might seem like a relatively normal reaction
for anyone descending into the depths of the
ocean to meet with a monster they don’t
know anything about, but Dr Williams was a
seasoned professional who had been on hundreds
of such missions before.
There was no logical reason for him to act
like this.
Although the reaction of Dr. Williams was
the most extreme, he wasn’t the only one
who started to feel strange.
Multiple agents developed a creeping feeling
of unease that swept over them.
One of the calmer men tried to reason with
Dr Williams, asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was feeling.
That’s when things got even stranger.
Not only was the doctor extremely anxious,
but he now seemed incapable of giving a real
response to any questions thrown at him.
He could only mutter that he was missing something
but he wasn’t sure what.
Knowing that many SCPs can bend reality and
the human mind, many of the personnel began
to have second thoughts about the mission
and even asked for permission to call off
the mission.
But they were mandated to continue — so
on they went.
As the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean, things only got worse.
Even the previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy, while the ones who were
already anxious were now sweating and jittering.
As for Dr Williams, he was now pacing back
and forth around the submarine, saying things
nobody could understand.
Every time he looked at his colleagues and
close friends, he seemed to stare straight
through them and would call them by the wrong
names.
It was as if his mind had moved to a different
dimension.
Whenever someone asked him to perform his
normal duties, he looked more confused than
ever.
Still, the team went deeper.
Dr Williams began to whimper and say the word
“no” repeatedly, growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others were
forced to sedate him.
Just then, something came into view.
It was what would come to be known as SCP-3000.
The thing was huge — so huge that its whole
body couldn’t be seen out of the submarine
window.
It was a horrible, eel-looking creature with
a head as big as a town and haunting eyes
that lit up the black ocean around it.
But perhaps the strangest part was that this
giant eel seemed to be producing a weird,
gray liquid.
Even the sedative wasn’t enough to keep
Dr Williams calm anymore.
There was a strange, blank look in his eyes,
as if the light and life had left them.
He just began screaming “no” repeatedly
again and wouldn’t respond to any attempts
to calm him down.
Not that anyone else was very capable of calming
him down at this point.
Even the crew members that had been holding
up well were starting to act strangely, and
nobody could get the image of those ominous
eyes out of their heads.
Then, things went from bad to worse.
Williams began screaming and shouting madly
as if he was being tortured by an unseen force.
The men tried to restrain him, but it was
no use.
He began smashing his head against the submarine
window until it cracked, putting the whole
mission and everyone’s life at risk.
He fell to the ground, injured, chanting that
there was nothing.
Whatever that meant.
It was an emergency scenario.
They began applying first aid to Williams
and the submarine ascended to the surface
as quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window to
explode.
By the time they reached the surface, Williams
was dead.
But there was something even more chilling
than the circumstances of his death.
Every single man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days that
came afterward: the image of the eel-like
creature's eyes seemed burned in their minds
permanently.
It would haunt their waking hours for the
rest of their lives and sleep was no escape
either, as they would appear in both their
dreams and nightmares alike forever.
A second mission had to be sent to gather
more information about this strange beast.
Already, there were many theories and question
marks surrounding SCP-3000.
How big was it really?
Was it sentient?
What was the liquid for?
None of the men who had been on the previous
mission were willing to return to the waters,
but a new group of brave recruits volunteered.
They were about to find out what so many in
history have learned the hard way - that bravery
and foolishness are often mistaken for the
same thing.
This time the mission would not be in a submarine,
but in dive suits, in order to observe the
anomaly in even closer detail, and to eliminate
the chance of one team member self-sabotaging
the submarine, killing them all.
They were transported to the location by boat
and the three men splashed into the ocean.
They descended, and at first, everything was
going well.
In case anything went wrong, the three of
them were tethered together for extra security.
But the deeper into the ocean they swam and
the closer they got to SCP-3000’s location
they got, the stranger things became.
Just like on the last mission.
First, there were a few minor cases of confusion.
One of the team, Jack, thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation — but
another, Roberto, also thought this was his
job.
In fact, navigation was actually the job of
a third team member, Amir, but he seemed to
have forgotten.
Everyone was getting confused.
The team listening in on the conversations
at Foundation headquarters grew increasingly
concerned about what they could hear.
Was everyone losing their minds?
Hopefully nobody was about to pull another
Dr Williams on them.
Still, the project leads couldn’t afford
to tell the men to come back to the surface.
The foundation badly needed any information
they could get on this SCP, whatever the cost,
so they told the men to press on.
Things only got worse.
Roberto was asking to speak to a colleague
who passed away two years ago, while the others
began to mutter indistinguishable phrases
about eyes and darkness.
Not too dissimilar to the ramblings of Dr
Williams.
It increasingly beginning to look like a suicide
mission.
Then, there was silence.
What was going on?
Each of the men had completely lost it, to
the point that they cut the tether that was
holding them together.
All alone, Jack couldn’t remember where
he was or why he was here.
He desperately looked around to try and gauge
his surroundings, but he could only see darkness.
All he could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of despair and
anxiety.
And this weird gray fluid that was now floating
in front of him.
The Foundation listened as Jack started reciting
a creepy speech about being on the edge of
nothing, inches from oblivion, with a sickness
in his mind and nothing but a pair of eyes
in front of him.
They listened in horror as they heard movement
through the radio.
It sounded like a huge creature was swimming
toward the men.
It had to be SCP-3000.
But all three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even see
what was in front of them, claiming they couldn’t
see anything in the darkness
There was silence for half a minute, with
the team listening in fearing the worst.
Then, they heard some more unintelligible
mutterings.
The men must be alive, but what on earth was
going on?
The gibberish started again.
Two of the men were screaming that Jack had
just been swallowed whole and that they were
being sucked in too.
Why couldn’t they just swim away?
It was chaos but then, a few moments later,
Roberto spoke into the radio, saying he was
floating alone in the middle of the ocean
and had now moved away from the eyes of SCP-3000.
He finally seemed capable of forming coherent
thoughts and speech.
After what had just happened, Roberto now
had a theory.
He thought that, somehow, it was impossible
to think straight around SCP-3000.
When he’d been close enough to see the eyes,
Roberto had felt a throbbing pain in his brain
and been unable to think about anything.
Perhaps it was something
to do with that mysterious
gray liquid.
Even more slime was now coming out of SCP-3000
now, and Roberto was determined to get a sample,
despite the warnings from HQ.
In one final burst of motivation, he swam
close enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample collection
unit that was designed to float to the surface
for collection later.
He had acquired some very important data,
but he seemed to have lost all hope of preserving
his life.
Roberto started telling the team over the
radio that he was dying that his heart rate
was too high, but cautioned that it would
be too dangerous for anyone to try and rescue
him.
The personnel continued to try and communicate
with Roberto to figure out what was going
on, but his words had stopped making any sense
until finally he went quiet.
Minutes turned into hours, hours turned into
days, and still, there was no sign of Roberto
or the rest of the divers.
After three days, his radio, which had only
been sending a steady stream of static, finally
stopped working altogether and he was presumed
dead.
However, the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of the
foundation researchers.
It turned out to be a viscous substance now
known as Y909, a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia.
Y909 causes head pain, paranoia, fear, panic,
memory loss, and confusion — explaining
what happened to Dr Williams and the diving
trio.
The collection of Y909 may have resulted in
two disastrous missions, but there’s a silver
lining as the substance ended up becoming
an invaluable tool for the SCP foundation.
Its ability to make people forget what just
happened to them can be used to eliminate
knowledge of threatening SCPs among the public.
It also helps the foundation staff cope with
the traumatic experiences they encounter on
their missions.
Although other amnestics can be used for the
same purpose, none are as powerful as the
one produced by SCP-3000.
Before its discovery, the amnestics used would
break down too quickly, not fare well in storage,
or cause undesirable side effects.
The only problem is the method of sourcing.
The only way to obtain Y909 is somewhat ethically
questionable for most people.
SCP-3000 produces Y909 after eating, so the
best way to stock up on it is by feeding the
creature.
Sedated D-class personnel from the foundation
are sent on missions supposedly to observe
the anomaly up close, unaware that this mission
is one way only.
Other divers are then sent later to collect
the fluid from a safe distance and store it.
Of course, it’s all for the greater good
of humanity.
Now, the foundation protects SCP-3000 as best
as it can guard something hundreds of kilometers
long.
The area is carefully patrolled and members
of the public are not allowed to enter the
part of the bay where it resides.
Anybody who accidentally comes into contact
is contained.
Eventually another pair of Foundation doctors
went down in a submarine to try and learn
more about SCP-3000.
One became so affected by Y909 that he began
hallucinating.
He started talking about Anantashesa, the
king of serpents in Hinduism.
Anantashesa is believed to be all that will
be left after the end of the world because
it exists throughout all of time simultaneously.
The doctor said he believed that this was
in fact Anantashesa, that SCP-3000 simply
shows us that eventually everyone dies and
fades into the darkness of oblivion,right
before he exited the submarine and swam right
into its mouth.
Luckily for now, SCP-3000 seems to be in a
sort of hibernation state.
It rarely moves and it doesn’t hunt — although
it will eat when fed.
But no one knows when or if it will wake,
or what it is capable of if it does.
Will it destroy the world?
Or simply drive us all insane.
A month ago, Dr. Robert Maxwell was a senior
researcher working at the facility, but a
tragic mistake had cost the lives of several
of his co-researchers.
Now he was being led down a bleak hallway
in Armed Bio-Containment Area-14, a rifle-wielding
guard flanking him on either side.
The once rising researcher had a very different
title now: D-8724.
He had been made a D-Class personnel… a
death sentence.
However, as the guards led him to his possible
demise, he wasn’t dressed in the typical
D-Class orange jumpsuit.
No, he was dressed in frilly, rococo dining
wear more typical of 18th century France.
If anything, Dr. Maxwell looked like he was
on his way to meet royalty.
And, in a sense, he was.
The former researcher had begged for any other
assignment, but the site director insisted
on committing Dr. Maxwell to teatime with
SCP – 082.
He’d always been the talkative type, so
the two would make a perfect pairing, and
if the creature found him sufficiently amusing,
then Maxwell might even leave the containment
cell alive.
He’d heard legends of the giant creature
they called The Cannibal.
Maxwell hoped they were just stories.
Dr. Maxwell was pushed by the guards into
a large, luxuriously-appointed room and the
doors were locked behind him.
He felt like a child, surrounded by freakishly
large furniture and ten foot high ceilings.
The fog of obnoxious floral perfumes couldn’t
fully cover up the pervasive smell of death
that lingered in the cavernous halls of 082’s
palace.
Thanks to an elaborate ruse conducted by the
Foundation, SCP-082 believed he was the king
of France, and that his containment cell was
a palace where he remained for his own safety.
The creature’s continued good behaviour
and everyone else’s safety relied on visitors
keeping up that lie.
Maxwell had never worked in this area of the
facility, so a lot of the standard procedures
were new to him.
Still, his superior had given him a clear
directive: Talk to the monster, communicate
with him.
Be cordial and friendly.
See if you can find out more about his mysterious
past.
And most importantly: If you want to survive,
don’t annoy him.
The down-on-his-luck scientist gulped and
sighed, trying to steady his nerves in this
oversized, fake French palace.
He just kept thinking “Surely he can’t
be that big?”
He almost talked himself into believing that
the accounts of the creature were just that
- tall tales - until a huge figure began lumbering
into the main chamber.
It was him: SCP – 082, also known as Fernand
The Cannibal.
SCP-082 was an eight-foot-tall hulking monster,
built sturdier than the castles it likes to
imagine are its true home.
Swollen, bloated, and grossly out of proportion,
the creature clocks in at over seven hundred
pounds – most of which is pure muscle that’s
almost impossible to pierce with conventional
weaponry.
SCP-082 stopped just feet away and stared
at Dr. Maxwell with its beady, sunken-in eyes,
like a hungry rat.
Just the sight of it struck terror into Dr.
Maxwell’s heart, but he didn’t dare show
his fear.
Instead he remembered his brief training,
bowing politely and forcing a smile, referring
to the creature as “your highness” and
profusely thanking it for granting him an
audience.
The monster continued staring without saying
anything and then gave a wide, lock-jawed
grin, showing off its huge teeth.
It did everything through gritted teeth, except
eat and sing.
Dr. Maxwell hoped he wouldn’t be a part
of either activity.
Fernand gave a low, booming chuckle.
He thanked Dr. Maxwell for coming to give
him some company and invited him to come further
inside and take a seat.
Adding, with a sly wink, that he won’t bite.
The monster complained that he so rarely gets
visitors to the palace these days – but
he omitted the fact that the main reason for
this was his tendency to devour them.
Maxwell nodded and followed the giant deeper
into its oversized abode.
He couldn’t help but notice that the monster’s
arms looked like huge, fleshy punching bags.
He knew that if Fernand wanted to, he could
easily crush him flat, just like he’d done
to so many unfortunate guards during containment
breaches.
Fernand told Dr. Maxwell that he was thinking
of having some decorating work done.
The walls of his palace were starting to look
awfully drab and he gestured to one covered
with a rusty red streak.
Maxwell remembered that D-Class cleaners were
sent into the containment cell twice a month
to tidy any of Fernand’s messes, but they
often ended up becoming one the messes themself.
The creature encouraged Maxwell to take a
seat at his oversized dining table, while
he tended to a pot of what he said was full
of delicious onion soup.
Maxwell obliged his host’s request and took
a seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the grownups’
table.
Meanwhile, Fernand was using a huge machete-like
knife to cleave onions in half for his bubbling
pot of stew.
Even though Fernand had shown no signs of
outward aggression, as he watched the Cannibal
hack away at onions with his enormous knife,
Maxwell could feel himself beginning to sweat.
After all, they didn’t call this creature
“The Cannibal” for nothing – this was
a monster with a truly horrifying body count.
During previous containment breaches it had
taken enough tranquilizer to put down two
elephants to subdue the creature, but not
before multiple agents quite literally lost
their heads in the process.
Fernand was able to bite them off with one
huge chomp, like he was eating a drumstick,
snapping right through bone with his incredible
tooth and jaw strength
Surprisingly when he wasn’t on a violent
rampage, foundation researchers had found
SCP-082 to be unusually polite and forthcoming,
offering the researchers plenty of information
about himself and his past.
The only problem was that almost everything
the creature said was a complete lie.
From his time as a researcher, Maxwell knew
that there were only a few details about the
creature that could be ascertained for certain
- SCP-082 would reliably answer to the name
“Fernand”, and genetically, Fernand was
technically human.
The means by which Fernand became so grotesquely
huge, strong, and cannibalistic are still
unknown – Foundation personnel are still
looking into whether it’s due to some kind
of anomalous genetic mutation, or by more
supernatural means.
All we know is that he’s big, unpredictable,
and extremely dangerous.
Dr. Robert Maxwell sat, terrified, at the
dining table of SCP – 082, listening to
Fernand’s slightly dull blade chop through
the final onion, which he then tossed into
the boiling soup.
Fernand had switched the topic of conversation
to one of his favorite fictional characters
– Hannibal Lecter.
Of course, Hannibal the Cannibal isn’t quite
so fictional to Fernand.
While he’s been shown to be extremely intelligent
in terms of puzzle-solving and memory, he
seems to have no understanding of the distinction
between fiction and reality.
He assumes all movies and TV shows are a form
of documentary or reality television.
And ever since seeing The Silence of the Lambs,
Fernand has been eager to meet with Dr. Lecter,
which he emphasized to Maxwell over and over.
Since trying to explain the concept of fiction
to Fernand has never previously worked, Maxwell
simply told him that Dr. Lecter is extremely
busy at the moment, but will visit whenever
he gets a chance.
This seemed to satisfy Fernand, who placed
two large bowls of steaming soup on the table
before sitting down a little too close to
Maxwell.
He couldn’t help but notice that the giant
cannibal was now sitting within biting distance,
and as a lowly D-Class, nobody would be rushing
in to save him if things went south.
Fernand began ranting through his clenched
teeth once more, occasionally stopping to
consume a hefty spoonful of onion soup.
Maxwell was sure to do the same, not wanting
to seem anything less than polite.
But soon, the tenor of Fernand’s rant began
to shift.
Typically, the monster spoke French or heavily
accented English.
Now, he was affecting the accent of a Victorian
gentleman, peppering his speech with “tally
ho” and “the game is afoot.”
Maxwell was confused at first, but quickly
realized the game Fernand was playing.
It’s well known that Fernand is a pathological
liar who likes to play numerous characters,
changing his mannerisms and clothes accordingly.
These personas have included: A vampire, Big
Bird, André the Giant, Foundation researcher
Dr. Bright, The Incredible Hulk, Alexander
The Great, Captain Hook, Dr. Frankenstein,
and Frankenstein's Monster.
And of course, in this case, the iconic fictional
detective Sherlock Holmes.
Fearing for his life in this strange situation,
Dr. Maxwell did the only thing he could - Play
along.
As Fernand reeled off his Holmesian delusions,
Maxwell began to play the role of Dr. John
Watson, asking follow-up
questions and complimenting
Fernand’s “impeccable” deductive reasoning.
And it seemed to be working – Fernand played
along too, acting as though the two of them
really were Arthur Conan Doyle’s crime-fighting
duo.
Towards the end of their game, Dr. Maxwell
was even starting to enjoy it, amazed that
his quick thinking was actually keeping him
safe.
But just then the Cannibal froze, as if in
a trance.
He locked eyes with Dr. Maxwell – like a
mad dog, that you can’t tell if it’s going
to bite you or not.
He saw the creature’s gargantuan teeth separating,
its huge jaws stretching open.
This could surely only mean one thing.
Dr. Maxwell winced and prepared for death,
cursing that all his quick thinking had amounted
to nothing.
Fernand leaned towards him, his gaping maw
with its hot onion scented breath just inches
away from Maxwell.
And then… he began to sing – the Cannibal
broke into a raucous Victorian pub song, happy
and jovial.
In his moment of terror, Dr. Maxwell had forgotten
that this was the other reason SCP – 082
opens his nightmarish jaws.
Relief washed over him, as he knew he was
safe, at least for a moment.
Not long after, foundation guards arrived
and escorted him from the cell, leaving the
delusional giant to his own devices back in
the so-called palace.
The former researcher had done it, he had
bested Fernand the Cannibal and hopefully
it would be the last time he’d ever be face
to face with that deranged giant.
Unfortunately for Dr. Robert Maxwell, in a
performance review later that week, one of
his superiors remarked that Fernand enjoyed
his company and he had done a great job.
Such a good job in fact, that Fernand insisted
he have Dr. Maxwell for dinner... or any other
meal for that matter... sometime very soon.
A veteran worker of the SCP Foundation sits
at his terminal, performing one of the most
critical tasks in the entire organization
- creating a file for an as yet undescribed
SCP.
But there’s something terribly wrong.
His eyes are glazed over, his mouth hangs
open - is this a zombie or a trained foundation
researcher?
What is going on?
Like any large international organization,
it takes more than just the exciting, action
filled jobs to keep the wheels turning at
the SCP Foundation.
Sure, the head researchers, guards, mobile
task force soldiers, and members of the O5
Command get all the praise, but a legion of
number crunchers, cleaners, and paper pushers
are equally important.
One such person was archivist Walter Bainbridge,
who had been tasked with digitizing some of
the older records that the Foundation had
on file.
It was when he was innocently recording the
details on SCP - 050 through 060 that he first
came under the strange and startling effects
of SCP - 055.
But, the most peculiar
part, as with all incidences
of SCP - 055’s anomalous effects taking
hold, is that Walter had no idea any of it
was happening.
In his new digitized filing system, he first
took note of SCP - 053.
Euclid Class, also known as the Young Girl,
this anomaly was a seemingly normal human
female child who provoked homicidal insanity
in those directly exposed to her.
Then SCP - 054.
Safe Class, a non-aggressive humanoid female
made entirely of, as well as biologically
and chemically identical to regular spring
water.
Next, SCP - 056.
Euclid Class, a being that changes form to
suit its environment, but only when all observers
lose focus on it.
And then SCP - 057.
Safe Class, an underground chamber that crushes
the humans who walk within.
It was at this point that Walter received
a concerned message from one of his superiors
at Site-19, Mr. Kovach.
The message praised the thorough digitization
of the other anomalies’ records, but was
confused about why Walter had left out any
mention of SCP - 055.
Immediately, Walter was embarrassed.
How could he have forgotten SCP - 055?
That iconic anomaly known for...Well, he couldn’t
quite say, off the top of his head, but he’d
be sure to look into it.
A quick trip to the Site 19 Archives showed
him that there was actually quite a hefty
file on the nature of SCP - 055, which must
have been the result of a huge number of studies.
What struck him as strange was that all the
files were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up, like a traditional file.
The majority of these notes were written in
short-hand, too, as though they were frantically
taken during the tests themselves on extremely
short notice.
There weren’t even any redactions.
Walter made a mental note of what he had seen,
put the file back in its proper place, and
headed back to his computer terminal.
However, after writing in an almost trancelike
state, he looked back on his work to see that
he had written an entry on SCP - 058, a giant,
evil bovine heart with insect legs and a scorpion
stinger…
Strange, he thought.
That’s when Walter got a call from Mr. Kovach
on his Foundation-issue phone, and he didn’t
sound happy.
He’d given Walter direct instructions to
go back and digitize the files on 055, and
instead, he’d been working on 058.
What was the meaning of this?
Walter was typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee, but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering talking
back, just this once, and hoping it didn’t
get him demoted to D-Class and thrown into
682’s acid bath for play time.
Walter gulped, picked up some courage, and
interrupted Mr. Kovach’s rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP - 055 actually was.
The line went silent for a moment, then the
supervisor spoke again, this time with less
confidence.
“Of course I can tell you about SCP - 055.
It’s a classic, one of the first hundred.
How could you forget its...Or, um, you know,
its...I think it’s the one with the...”
Another long pause, as Mr. Kovach seemed to
search for the words, but instead just trailed
off into silence.
Knowing that some of the anomalies on file
were dangerous memetic hazards, Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have accidentally
killed his boss by getting him to think too
hard about SCP - 055.
He asked if Mr. Kovach was okay, and finally
got a reply.
“I’m sorry, I seem to have zoned out for
a second there.
What were we talking about, again?”
But this time, it was Walter who couldn't
answer.
He had no idea at all what the two of them
were discussing just moments ago.
He felt disoriented and kind of sick, like
they’d taken some low-level amnestics.
Mr. Kovach told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they’d speak later.
Walter then checked the messages he’d received
from Mr. Kovach earlier, and there it was,
plain as day: “You missed 055.
Go back and digitize that before proceeding.
- Mr. K.”
But Walter had never even heard of an SCP
- 055, if such an anomaly even existed!
What was going on here?
In that moment, Walter realized he was dealing
with something much stranger than just a standard
digitization job.
After all, how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP - 055 seemed to be impossible
to speak, write, or even think about, unless
you were directly observing it at that moment?
Walter had to know, and ask around the entirety
of Site 19 to find the answers if he had to.
Sadly for Walter, he was about to embark on
a much more challenging task than he could
have ever imagined.
To paraphrase a supposed quote from Socrates,
“All I know is that I know nothing.”
And that’s also about the extent of the
knowledge we have on SCP - 055, also known
as The Anti-Meme and the Self-Keeping Secret.
What does it look like?
When and how was it obtained by the Foundation?
What are its anomalous abilities?
Is this thing dangerous?
We may never know, because the only anomalous
ability of SCP - 055 that we’re aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of retaining
any information about it.
It’s crucial to note that, whatever 055
is, it isn’t invisible, or indescribable.
Foundation personnel are perfectly capable
of entering its containment chamber and observing
it without incident, but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber, any
memories of the particulars
of 055 seem to spontaneously erase themselves.
Hence, the Self-Keeping Secret.
But this didn’t deter Walter.
Perhaps his greatest advantage was that he
didn’t know enough about the thing he was
investigating to know how futile his mission
was.
He wanted to know the unknowable, and a pesky
issue like “impossibility” wouldn’t
stop him.
He’d get to whoever he needed to at Site
19 to get the answers he needed.
Of course most people had no knowledge of
the mysterious anomaly.
The common response he got
back from his colleagues
was, “055?
Do we even have an 055?”
While the realization of sudden memory loss
- or the realization of 055’s existence
- has been known to cause momentary stress,
there are no known long term physical or mental
effects from 055’s anomalous abilities.
It’s a fleeting idea in its purest form
- like forgetting why you walked into a room.
055 could be the most harmless object on the
Foundation’s roster, or the most deadly.
Either way, we just don’t know.
At times, Walter worried he was going insane.
055, and everything related to it, was gaslighting
him.
Was 055 even real?
The one thing that proved to him that 055
must have existed is that its containment
chamber existed.
According to the official records kept by
the Foundation on the Site 19 Containment
Facilities, 055 is kept in a “five by five
by two point five meter square room constructed
of fifty-foot-thick cement, with a Faraday
cage surrounding the cement walls.”
The report continues that, “Access is via
a heavy containment door measuring two by
two point five meters constructed on bearings
to ensure door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately.”
055’s cell is one of the few to have no
posted security guards, and any personnel
working on other SCPs in the area are ordered
to remain at least fifty feet from the geometric
center of 055’s cell, where the anomaly
itself is kept.
When he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner, he found that
- surprise, surprise - nobody knew.
055 was an anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a Keter Class designation.
After all, how can you properly contain something
you can’t even hope to comprehend?
There were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of 055.
Some of the more conspiratorial minds at Site
19 theorized that 055 was actually an autonomous
or remotely controlled spy inserted into the
site to observe Foundation operations - or
even humanity as a whole.
If you’re on the more paranoid end of the
psychological spectrum, this theory makes
total sense.
An anomaly that’s physically impossible
to remember, even when writings and pictures
on the subject exist, would be a perfect spy.
However, this was all ultimately little more
than speculation.
Walter was barely any further along than when
he started.
There were multiple points in his investigation
where Walter seriously considered giving up,
until, finally, he had a major breakthrough.
Dr. Bartholomew Hughes and Dr. John Marachek
were two scientists that had performed extensive
research into 055, and who - Walter hoped
- might have the answers he sought about the
Self-Keeping Secret.
These scientists were the first to discover
the “Anti-Memetic” nature of 055, performing
numerous tests on D-Class personnel to see
if it was possible to create feasible written
records, sketches, or any other records or
impressions that could bypass its anomalous
effects.
The disorienting, memory-ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials concerning
055.
It seemed to be a truly uncrackable code,
but Dr. Hughes may have finally found some
cracks in the armor.
For starters, the fact we’re able to remember
that 055 is Anti-Memetic is an ironic exception
to its Anti-Memetic qualities.
This revelation also inspired another realization
from Dr. Hughes: Would it be possible to discover
more about 055 from the process of deduction
rather than the typical induction?
In other words, could they possibly learn
about 055 by figuring out all the things it
isn’t rather than what it is?
Dr. Marachek designed an experiment with Dr.
Hughes to explore this theory.
They designed the experiment around a simple
question: Is 055 not spherical?
In designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn’t, they hoped to subvert
the anomaly’s Anti-Memetic Powers.
Walter was fascinated by this potential method
of getting answers.
Marachek and Hughes found that, while the
questioning process for those exposed was
often arduous and frustrating, they could
now definitely say that 055 is not a sphere.
It is theoretically possible to discover the
true nature of 055 by an almost endless barrage
of deductive questions, though whether command
would authorize the resources for such extensive
testing is still an open question.
Walter, in his desperation, begged Marachek
and Hughes for clearance to view 055 himself.
The curiosity had become too great during
his search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 wasn’t spherical.
He needed to see this thing.
And after several weeks of filling out forms
and cutting red tape, his wish was finally
granted.
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP - 055, the subject of his months-long
obsession.
Outsiders observed that Walter spent just
over an hour in the containment chamber, taking
photos, drawing sketches, writing down notes,
recording audio logs, and reciting memory
mnemonics.
He was pulling out every stop to counteract
the anti-memetic effects of the Self-Keeping
Secret.
He was adamant that he would not be defeated
by his non-spherical nemesis, not after all
this time and effort.
Once his time in the 055 containment chamber
was over, he retired back to his office to
finally digitize his exhaustive findings,
so that his supervisor, Mr. Kovach, would
finally get off his back.
Walter smiled, took a deep breath, and began
to type.
“SCP - 059.
Keter Class.
This anomaly is a radioactive mineral that
emits a unique radiation known as Delta Radiation.
Exposure to this radiation has caused strange
fungal growths on the infected...”
Wait, what was this supposed to be about again?
Oh well, it couldn’t have been that important.
The fabric of our world is littered with doorways
if you know where to look for them. Tears,
portals, anomalies, all leading to places and
planes beyond human imagining and understanding,
and SCP-2317, otherwise known as A Door to
Another World, certainly fits that description.
Contained and kept at all times
under the watch of armed guards,
SCP-2317 appears to be a simple and unsuspecting
wooden door in its frame. It hardly looks like it
requires such extreme round-the-clock security
or needs a strange, secretive ritual that the
Foundation performs, presumably to keep the
door closed. But, of course, sometimes the
most interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn’t where it leads, it’s what it keeps out.
Even by the Foundation’s already-high standards,
the requirements and regulations for personnel
who are assigned to SCP-2317 seem oddly specific.
Psychological testing is standard practice for to
work for the Foundation, but an additional
hurdle that anyone has to clear before even
getting to glimpse at this unassuming wooden
door is having a score of at least seventy-two
on the Milgram Obedience Examination. It is also
mandatory that personnel assigned to maintaining
it are both unmarried, with no children
or next-of-kin, as well as an unwavering,
unquestioning loyalty to the Foundation,
pure devotion to its code and objectives.
These may seem like strange requirements,
after all, SCP-2317 is just a door…isn’t it?
Perhaps there’s a reason that the Foundation
keeps so much of the information about SCP-2317
buried deep under layers upon layers of security,
with only the Overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature. Knowledge, as they
say, is power - but maybe knowing too much about
whatever is behind that door can prove deadly.
Still, if SCP-2317 is a Door to Another World,
an alternate dimension or parallel reality,
it must be safe enough to visit. After all,
the Foundation has been sending personnel
in there on a regular basis. Daily, in fact.
According to the O5 Council, this
is done as part of a procedure to
maintain Active Containment of…something
lurking beyond that old wooden doorframe.
But what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance?
In accordance with the Foundation’s guidelines,
all staff are required to rotate out of observing
SCP-2317 after every two months and spend the
following third month in full psychological
counselling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing the
Door to Another World. It was after one of
these month-long periods of evaluation that
a Foundation guard was informed that his security
clearance had been raised to Level 3 and that he’d
been selected for the duty of carrying out
220-Calabasas. He knew the name instantly;
this was the title given to the daily containment
procedure that absolutely had to be carried out.
The guard didn’t question these orders, after
all, he’d been selected precisely because of
his loyalty to the Foundation. He did make one
request to his commanding officer, however:
he wanted to know what had happened to the
last guard that had performed the procedure.
“Didn’t make it out of psychological
evaluation,” the officer replied.
Not letting this affect his dedication, the guard
was told to prepare for Procedure 220-Calabasas.
Along with a fellow member of Foundation security
personnel, the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list. The first was
a pre-selected member of Class-D Personnel,
specifically a convicted murderer. Class-D
refers to ‘Disposable Class’ personnel,
expendable individuals recruited by the
Foundation for the sole purpose of testing SCPs.
Class-Ds were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing, and the
one chosen for 220-Calabasas was no exception,
serving multiple life sentences for murders,
or at least that was what the guard
had been told. A Foundation personnel
member instructed him to refer to the Class-D
solely as the ‘assistant’ from that point on.
Next, the guard collected a live
chicken, an obsidian-edged knife,
a silver aspergillum and aspersorium, to be
filled with 500ccs of Holy Water that had
been blessed by a priest of the Abrahamic faith,
and finally a one-kiloton nuclear device, which,
according to instructions, was to only
be detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure.
In other words, the last resort.
After following his instructions to the letter and
without question, the guard and his colleague were
briefed. The Foundation personnel member informed
them that he’d be joining and leading them in the
procedure. The staff member also specified that
henceforth he be referred to as the ‘celebrant’
until the completion of 220-Calabasas. The
guard was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were, but trusted in the Foundation,
knowing that if they wanted this procedure
performed a certain way, then it was in everyones’
best interest to carry out the orders to the
letter. But what the celebrant then went on to
explain, raised far more questions about SCP-2317
and the nature of Procedure 220-Calabasas. The
Class-D joining them, wasn’t actually a Class-D.
The assistant, as they were now referred to,
was in reality another Foundation staff member,
with a Level 4 security clearance, specifically
tailored to SCP-2317. Every member of staff
entering through SCP-2317 and taking an active
role in 220-Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or treated
as a member of Disposable Class. Fighting back
the nagging question of why the Foundation would
employ this subterfuge, the guard, along with
his fellow security officer, the celebrant and
assistant, prepared for their departure through
the Door to Another World at solar noon, when
the sun was highest over SCP-2317. Solar noon,
chickens and holy water, this all seemed like
an oddly-occult combination for the Foundation.
As they entered the old wooden door, beyond
lay a barren salt plane, stretching out for
kilometers in every direction. This alternate
dimension, according to the briefing,
was designated SCP-2317-Prime. The guard
immediately noticed a ring of seven pillars
directly ahead of the group as they entered, each
of them bearing intricately-detailed engravings
unlike anything from any era of ancient history.
Procedure 220-Calabasas was carried out quickly,
but carefully, the guard watching as the celebrant
and assistant were careful not to miss a step.
First, the celebrant scattered Holy Water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium, looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady pace as he
stepped counter-clockwise around them. The guard
watched intently as the celebrant completed his
circuit around the pillars and turned to the
assistant, anointing his head with Holy Water.
“Seven Seals, Seven Rings, Seven Thrones
for the Scarlet King,” he said aloud.
The assistant, with the obsidian blade in
his hand, took the chicken and dispatched it
in sacrifice, letting its blood mix with the
Holy Water. He then repeated the celebrant’s
circuit in the opposite direction, before
stepping into the center of the stone pillars.
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New King,”
the assistant recited, pouring the remaining mix
of blood and Holy Water over a patch of
salt in the middle of the seven pillars.
Even though he knew it wasn’t his place to
question the Foundation, as the 220-Calabasas
procedure took place, the guard couldn’t
help but wonder what all this was for.
It seemed so…ritualistic, like something
deeply religious or even magical. He’d never
bought into all that occult mumbo-jumbo,
even while working for the Foundation,
but he had learned not to question anything, even
the strangest and most inexplicable of sights.
Little did he know that beneath his feet, was an
ancient and unknowable horror. A beast, chained
and lying in wait. Contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars, sat an impossibly-large
creature. Humanoid and obese, its body covered
entirely in scales thicker than armour plating.
Branch-like horns protruded from its jawless
head, pointing up to chains that hung from the
seven pillars above, each one hooked into the
entity’s back. All but one of the chains was
broken, a final, withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds in its underground prison.
Ever since 1894 BCE, when Erikeshan mystics
imprisoned it, the Devourer has been waiting
patiently for its inevitable freedom. It knows,
as well as the Foundation, that nothing can be
done to prevent the final chain from one day
breaking. Even Procedure 220-Calabasas won’t
keep the creature contained, it’s nothing more
than a smokescreen, an act, designed to create
an illusion of active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent solution
can be devised to keep SCP-2317 imprisoned.
Of course, if the guard had known this, it would
have also explained the need for a one-kiloton
nuclear device as part of this staged ritual.
Procedure 220-Calabasas has all the components
to trick everyone below the O5 Council,
emulating religious and occult rituals, the
increased level of security surrounding the
procedure and its purpose, and telling staff
that any failure to correctly, and completely,
perform the 220-Calabasas procedure will result
in an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
All these elements work together to conceal
the truth: that one day, the Devourer will
escape and lay waste to our dimension.
Knowledge is power, and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly. Perhaps if the guard had
learned any of this, he’d have understood why
his predecessor never made it out of psychological
evaluation. Maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of Procedure 220-Calabasas, he'd have learned the
true nature of SCP-2317, and what that doorway
kept out. But he was loyal to the Foundation,
through and through. As the team finished
performing 220-Calabasas and returned though the
wooden door, the guard took one last glance over
his shoulder at the vast salt plane. The entire
dimension was calm, silent, but not peaceful:
it was patient. The entity had waited centuries
for its time, and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain. One day.
The door was closed behind the guard as he,
the celebrant, the assistant and his fellow
security officer stepped back through,
their work done and, as far as they knew,
preventing catastrophe for another day.
Only the Foundation higher-ups, the Overseer
Council, are aware of the true danger posed
by SCP-2317 and its sole inhabitant. Current
predictions are that at some point within the
next thirty years, the Devourer of Worlds will
be freed. Any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place have so
far failed. As such, the O5 Council has elected
to continue providing Foundation personnel with
the ignorant hope that Procedure 220-Calabasas
is an effective strategy for containment.
As we’ve said, sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed door isn’t where it leads,
it’s what it keeps out. In the case of SCP-2317,
the unassuming wooden door holds at bay
an ancient creature of untold power,
that will one day break free and wreak havoc in
our dimension. Nothing the Foundation does can
prevent it, or keep it contained behind the
Door to Another World, and only the Overseer
Council knows that any and all efforts to
do so are futile. With all that in mind,
we can only hope that the doorway of SCP-2317
stays closed, at least for a little while longer.
It was November 3rd, 1991 and Blake Newsom
loved his job.
He had a passion for organization, an undying
love of American political history, and was
a life-long member of the Republican party.
That’s why he took great pride in his position
as a filing clerk at the
Ronald Reagan Presidential
Library.
Or at least, he did, until his horrifying
encounter with SCP – 1981.
The worst day of Blake’s life began like
any other.
He was taking inventory of the archive’s
wide array of Betamax tapes, and making sure
they were all arranged carefully and conformed
with the filing system.
One by one, he checked footage of speeches
and addresses off of his list, until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business being
there.
The tape looked to be completely normal, but
it hadn’t been recorded on the archive inventory.
And there was something else off about it.
A single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with “RONALD REGAN CUT UP WHILE
TALKING" scrawled hastily with what was probably
a felt-tipped marker.
Blake was shocked and appalled – they hadn’t
even spelled the President’s name correctly!
What poor Mr. Newsom didn’t know was that
he was about to see something so disturbing
that he’d look back on that misspelling
like it was a treasured childhood memory.
Standard policy for tapes like this would
be to review and catalogue, or even throw
it out if necessary.
Typically, a lowly filing clerk like Blake
would need to seek approval from his superiors,
but curiosity got the better of him.
He commandeered one of the library’s televisions
and Betamax cassette players, and started
watching the footage.
For the first minute or so nothing seemed
out of the ordinary, just the president standing
at a podium giving his iconic “Evil Empire”
speech to the National Association of Evangelicals
at Sheraton Twin Towers Hotel, Orlando, Florida,
on March 8th, 1983.
However, the second the tape hit the one minute
and ten seconds mark, something unnatural
began to occur.
President Reagan’s speech began to veer
off, as the topic of conversation shifted
from the importance of family values to the
exquisite taste of human flesh.
Blake was taken aback.
Surely, he was hearing things?
But the tape only got worse.
President Reagan began to divulge the fact
that he enjoyed the taste of young flesh the
best, particularly that of infants.
As Reagan began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an infant if
you want to seal in the flavour, the crowd
erupted into modest applause.
Blake started to feel sick.
He’d remembered watching this speech, and
President Reagan had said nothing of the sort!
Things only got weirder as the President’s
cheek suddenly opened up into a long, bleeding
gash, as though someone had cut into his face
with an invisible knife.
As the speech continued, and Reagan’s words
became more nonsensical and incoherent, the
injuries got worse, too.
His face developed puncture wounds, like he
was being stabbed.
Skin in some areas rotted and peeled off.
Reagan showed no awareness of the horrifying
injuries that seemed to be occurring spontaneously
on his body.
This was a living nightmare!
The tape came to a merciful end 22 minutes
in, after President Reagan’s throat appeared
to be slashed open and his insane speech was
reduced to quiet gurgles.
It fizzled out into static shortly after,
and Blake politely retired to the bathroom
to throw up.
Was this some sick prank or tampering or camera
trickery, perhaps?
He didn’t know but that tape was disgusting,
and whoever was responsible had to be punished.
Newsom contacted the police, hoping obscenity
charges could be pressed against the creator
of the tape once they were found.
The tape was taken into evidence, and a low-level
police investigation into the possible culprits
began.
While the police officers who viewed the tape
reported nightmares in the weeks following,
the creator of the tape was never found.
The investigation truly came to an end when
a superior closed the case
and the tape disappeared
from the evidence locker.
This, as you probably could have guessed,
was the work of a field agent from The SCP
Foundation.
Amnestics were then used to erase the memories
of everyone unlucky enough to witness the
tape, including Blake Newsom, who could finally
rest easy and return to his filing work.
The anomalous tape was now in responsible
hands.
It was given the designation SCP – 1981,
and given the object class “Safe” due
to its easily controlled and self-contained
nature.
Proper research and testing was now able to
begin and while nothing about the construction
of the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous, repeat viewings of the video made
it clear that this went far beyond mere doctored
footage of a Presidential speech.
Every single time the tape is played, both
the speech made and the injuries received
by President Reagan change.
The few rules the tape seems to always follow
are that Reagan never reacts to the injuries
he’s receiving, it always has the same beginning
and total runtime, and the speech is always
corrupted.
These speeches have been described as “mostly
incoherent, lacking any sort of underlying
thematic structure and largely being composed
of nonsensical anecdotes and parables”,
so not that dissimilar from a regular Reagan
speech, but the topics always turn incredibly
dark and have included torture, mutilation,
death, cannibalism, ritual sacrifice, genocide,
and more.
The range of injuries shown on President Reagan
in the videos have included, but are by no
means limited to, impalement, mutilation,
flaying, and some tortures so gruesome that
the details have been redacted from official
files.
On several occasions, the details of President
Reagan’s speech have also eerily predicted
the future.
These include successfully predicting the
September 11th attacks in 2001 and the outcome
of the 2008 Russian presidential election.
Incidentally, this isn’t
even the only Reagan-related
SCP to predict the future.
No, there’s another entry in this incredibly
specific niche: SCP – 095, a highly degraded
copy of a comic known as “The Atomic Adventures
of Ronnie Ray-Gun.”
The title character bears a striking resemblance
to President Reagan, despite the fact that
the comic is confirmed by Foundation tests
to have been written in the early 1930s.
The comic is set in the far-off future world
of the 1980s, and follows a number of Ronnie’s
exploits in three stories.
The first, titled “Ronnie vs. Space Admiral
Carter”, seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election.
The second, “Space Assassin!”, mirrors
the attempted assassination of President Reagan
by John Hinckley Jr.
And the third, titled “Jungle Planet!”,
retells the Iran-Contra controversies of 1986.
These comics were produced under the mysterious
and apparently non-existent company, “Future
Funnies.”
The Foundation hopes to track down the other
comics from this company whenever possible,
but they’ve had no luck on that front.
For now, there’s only SCP – 095.
During initial testing, Foundation staff watched
the tape frequently in case this strange,
corrupted version of President Reagan had
any other valuable predictions for the future.
However, during one of these screenings, one
of the D-Class observation personnel pointed
and yelled at the screen in horror.
Upon further examination of recorded footage,
researchers could see exactly what had concerned
the D-Class observer so much.
While, in other viewings of the tape, President
Reagan’s press detail had appeared totally
normal, in this one something was clearly
amiss.
Standing among the other dull, suit-wearing
political aides was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight-black cloak with a large, conical
hood obscuring his face.
The figure didn’t appear to move in the
footage – it just stood there, menacingly.
A later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven viewings
of the tape.
This cloaked figure was designated SCP – 1981
– 1, and he became part of the recurring
imagery in the nightmares that often followed
a viewing of SCP – 1981.
Naturally, despite containment and preservation
attempts, the Foundation was aware that just
like any normal tape,
natural magnetic interference
would eventually degrade it beyond use.
Attempts to copy the footage onto another
Betamax tape failed to reproduce the anomalous
effects.
That’s why the Foundation has painstakingly
recorded any video and audio they could via
a standard commercial camcorder.
In one particularly terrifying playback, SCP
– 1981 – 1 took the president’s place
at the podium, staring directly into the camera.
The words “I SEE YOU” appeared over a
black screen shortly after.
Staff members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure,
and instead contact a Level 4 superior if
such an event occurs during a playback again.
The frightening and unfortunate effects of
SCP – 1981 would come to their logical conclusion
under the watchful eye of Dr. James Kyle Robinson,
Managing Archivist of Inert Safe-Class Objects
and Anomalous Items at Site 73.
He was contacted by Special Agent Arnold Rodriguez
and Special Agent Ethan Tate, members of secret
service with a duty of care to President Reagan.
Word had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artefact in the possession of the
Foundation that directly pertained to him,
and he wanted to see it.
Dr. Robinson obtained files and transcripts
pertaining to SCP – 1981 and handed them
over to the Agents, but refused to allow President
Reagan to see the tape directly without approval
from O5 Command.
But Reagan and the agents were persistent.
Eventually, O5 Command ordered a private screening
of the tape for President Reagan at the Sanford
Chemical Processing Plant – a front business
owned and operated by the Foundation for Amnestic
production.
Dr. Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of Amnestics after the session completed,
but Reagan declined.
The screening took place in Conference Room
B, and the tape was re-played three times.
It was on the third playback that things took
an interesting turn.
As the mutilated Reagan on the screen began
to rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin, Reagan began
to silently mouth along to the words, as though
he remembered them.
He spoke about beings known as “The Destroyers”,
and potential apocalyptic events to come.
After the screening, Reagan once again refused
the offer of Amnestics, and departed.
It seemed as though all was well, until a
violent break-in at the
Sanford Chemical Processing
Plant that left the night guard dead.
A large number of Amnestics had been stolen
during the break-in, and security footage
showed that Agents Tate and Rodriguez had
been responsible.
The two agents were tracked down and traced
to the residence of Ronald Reagan, where the
Foundation came upon a disturbing sight: The
agents had pillaged large quantities of Class
A and B Amnestics and supplied them to President
Reagan, who – at some point after observing
SCP – 1981 – had been driven into a dangerous
madness.
The two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others, but their
bungling had come with severe consequences.
Misapplying such a high quantity of Amnestics
had essentially destroyed Reagan’s mind,
and while the Foundation was able to stabilize
his condition, his impaired memory and cognitive
function would leave him unable to care for
himself independently.
In order to cover up for this grievous mistake,
a cover story was concocted about Reagan falling
victim to Alzheimer’s and facing severe
cognitive decline as a result.
Both Agents Tate and Rodriguez were fired
for their actions, had their memories wiped
by the Foundation, and were
assigned new identities.
Dr. Robinson, for his part in the disaster,
had to face a Foundation Ethics Committee
Disciplinary Hearing.
While SCP – 1981 continues to be classified
as“Safe” due to its unlikeliness to ever
breach containment, when you consider the
havoc it wrought on the mind of its singular
target, “safe” is hardly the word that
comes to mind.
It’s enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there, just waiting
to be found
The Young Girl stood silently in a room full
of corpses, staring off into the distance.
She was in a trance, seemingly
unaware of the carnage that’d
just unfolded around her. Some of the
men were shot or stabbed or beaten,
others had no apparent cause of death whatsoever.
But the Young Girl was unscathed. She was wearing
a yellow summer dress and looked like she
couldn’t have been more than three years
old. She awoke from her trance, still paying
no heed to the violence in the room, and left.
This is the story of SCP - 053, the Young Girl.
Her strange and terrifying life before
containment, her thrilling capture,
and the part she played in one of the most
dangerous SCP Foundation cross-tests of all time.
She had no name. The Young Girl could
never spend enough time around someone
to be given one. It was her terrible curse that
she could never stay in one place for too long,
or something truly awful would happen to everyone
around her. She’d been drifting for years,
but never grew to look older than a child.
Her memories were long but formless - divided
mostly into ten-minute increments. The Young
Girl kept on moving. It was all she could do.
In 1993, when the Young Girl had already been
alive for a very long time, she found herself in
Illinois after days of trekking on the roadside.
She would scavenge what little food she needed
from the trash, and drink from lakes, rivers,
or even puddles when she needed to. Deep down,
the Young Girl knew that even if she grew
hungry or thirsty, she would not die.
In her travels, the Young Girl had managed
to scrounge together a few dollars,
and though she knew her contact
with people had to be limited,
there was one thing she wanted that felt worth
the risk: A candy bar. It’d been a long time
since she tasted chocolate, and she found
the idea of tasting it again too enticing
to resist. When she reached Chicago, she entered
a small corner store with her handful of dollars,
selected a candy bar from the rack, and
approached the counter. For reasons even
she didn’t fully understand, she kept her eyes
down as she placed the money on the counter.
You see, SCP - 053 was always a special
child. As we briefly mentioned earlier,
you might even say she was cursed. Whenever
she was around other people for too long,
terrible things tended to happen. Unspeakable
things. And as a component of this strange,
unexplainable curse - or perhaps as a
means of keeping her safe from it - the
Young Girl was doomed to never understand
the nature of her predicament. It was like
there was a mental wall between her and
the horrors her presence could cause.
All she knew was that it was best to avoid eye
contact, stay away from large groups of people
at all costs, and never spend any longer than
ten minutes around anyone. Ever. That’s why,
as she waited for her chocolate bar at the cash
register, she kept her head down and waited to go.
The cashier looked down upon this strange girl
with apparent concern. It’d been a slow day,
all in all. A few listless patrons milled
around the store, window shopping. His
brain was practically on autopilot, until he saw
this child. She looked filthy, in a dishevelled
dress and was totally alone. What on earth had
happened to this child? The more he looked at her,
the more he sensed a creepy vibe exuding from
her. Something about this girl was wrong.
He spoke softly to her, introducing himself
as Miles, and asking her where her mommy
and daddy were. The Young Girl hesitated for
just a few seconds too long for his liking,
before simply saying that they were at home.
Any parent who’d let their three-year-old kid
just wander around the South Side of Chicago
alone was either crazy, neglectful, or both.
He asked her politely to remain in the
store, while he gave the police a quick call.
He’d even let her have the candy
bar for free while she waited.
Immediately, the little girl became uncomfortable.
She’d already been in here for a few minutes now,
and while Miles called the police he
expected her to wait around even longer.
Again, she couldn’t even tell you why she knew
waiting around like this would be so dangerous,
but she had a nagging, instinctual awareness
that she needed to get out. Around the store,
the few patrons still inside started to get a
strange feeling, like someone was watching them.
Soon, what seemed like mild paranoia was
quickly becoming white-hot anger. Pure
rage. They felt almost like they had
to kill someone. But not just anyone.
Someone particular. They
had to kill the little girl.
It wasn’t long until the police arrived. Two
officers, Holiday and DeWitt, entered to collect
the apparently neglected little girl. It was
a story they’d sadly heard all too often - a
tragically common occurrence in the big city.
When the two of them approached the Young Girl,
she was looking down at the ground. They tried
to speak to her but she was unresponsive. Miles
looked on, concerned, but deep down, he
felt the same bizarre progression all the
other store-goers were feeling: Confusion,
irritability, and finally... violent rage.
The corner store was a powder keg,
all it needed now was a spark.
And that spark came when Officer Holiday reached
down, and took the Young Girl by the arm. His bare
skin touched her’s, and it was all over. The
cop twitched, his mind washed out in murderous
insanity, as he reached for his side-arm. Officer
DeWitt opened his mouth to protest, but he didn’t
manage to get a syllable out before Holiday turned
and shot him. In a fraction of a second, the quiet
corner store exploded into a violent bloodbath,
as the patrons and cops slaughtered each other.
All the while, the Young Girl
just stood there in a trance.
Everyone was dead within minutes, except Miles
and the Young Girl. He shakily rose to his feet,
his mind carved out by madness, and reached
for Officer Holiday’s discarded pistol.
Outside of the store, The Young Girl appeared,
walking out as if nothing had happened.
Inside, Miles’s body was sprawled over
the counter, clutching his chest
as if his heart had just exploded.
This was the true nature of the Young Girl’s
curse. Anyone who meets her eye, touches her skin,
or spends over ten minutes around her is
destined to slip into a state of murderous
insanity. They’ll go into a kill-crazy frenzy,
and attack anyone around them, until all that’s
left is them and the Young Girl. At which point,
they’ll try to kill her, too - but the mere act of
attempting to kill her is also fatal, killing its
victims with a massive heart attack or a seizure.
The second part of the girl’s curse
is that she herself can never die.
She keeps coming back, unknowingly causing
more misery and death along the way. Until,
of course, a certain secret
organization took notice.
That night, the Young Girl sat in the cavernous
interior of a local abandoned warehouse,
quietly eating her hard-earned candy bar.
Suddenly, she heard a quiet “crack” in the
distance. She tried to move her left arm, but
found it was numb. She could barely move it.
The Girl turned her head, and saw a tranquilizer
dart sticking out of her skin. Instinctively,
she got up and began to run, limping as her
left leg started to lose all feeling too.
Suddenly, she was surrounded by footsteps,
as masked men in SWAT uniforms emerged out
of the darkness on all sides. The last thing she
remembered before slipping out of consciousness
was a blindfold being pulled over her eyes, and
tiny metal handcuffs clasping over her wrists.
When she woke up, she was in the nicest room she’d
slept in in years. It was sixteen feet by sixteen
feet, with toys, books, and games. Standing
across the room from her was a stranger in
a full hazmat suit, connected to a long, steel
cable leading out of the room. He spoke calmly
and politely. A timer on his wrist counted down
from ten minutes. The stranger explained to the
Young Girl that they would be taking care of
her now, and would provide her with all the
toys and games and treats she wanted, provided she
cooperated and submitted willingly to some tests.
Compared to living out on the
streets with no food or comfort,
this seemed like an excellent compromise.
She would live in what seemed like luxury,
and every so often, she’d be taken to a testing
room with a stranger in an orange jumpsuit.
After a few minutes of waiting, the
stranger would inevitably go feral,
and attempt to kill her - and then always die in
the process. The strangers in the hazmat suits
told her that all of these tests were helping
them learn extremely valuable things about her,
and that soon, they’d have a very special job
for her. It would be a wonderful surprise.
It was in the spring of 1994 that the Young
Girl, now officially designated SCP - 053,
finally received her special mission. Several
strangers in full hazmat suits, wielding rifles,
escorted her out of her usual bedroom. She asked
where she was being taken, and was told she was
going to meet a new friend. She was taken
to one of the recreational testing rooms,
and pushed inside. Out in front of her, she saw
something terrifying: A giant, reptilian creature.
She retreated from it instinctually, hiding
behind a chair in the containment area. The
giant reptile didn’t move. It just sat there.
Eventually, she plucked up the courage to go
and touch the creature, before retreating
again. No reaction. Little by little,
the Young Girl gained confidence, and continued
to approach and pat the creature. It exhaled
through its huge nostrils, and the Young Girl
literally jumped for joy in her amusement.
She began to play with the docile monster,
hugging it, even drawing on it with a crayon.
The observers were truly baffled. What the
Young Girl didn’t know was that she was
playing with SCP - 682, one of the most hateful
and aggressive anomalies under the Foundation’s
watchful eye. And yet, in her presence, the
creature was like an overgrown puppy dog.
After the test phase, the Young Girl was removed
from the Hard-To-Kill Reptile’s presence,
immediately causing the creature to become
violent and murderous once again. After
being separated from her strange new friend, the
Young Girl was seen crying for several minutes.
According to all accounts, the Young Girl
is eager to see her friend again some day,
though considering the Reptile killed
several guards after their separation,
the Foundation isn’t eager to grant her that wish.
SCP-053 was classified as Euclid and
continues to be held in containment,
with her toys, books, and games rotated
out on a regular basis. Seeing as she
shows no sign of aging, this ongoing
containment is likely to be the sad,
strange fate of the Young Girl. An anomaly that
never wanted to hurt anyone - but an important
and cruel reminder that what we want doesn’t
always influence the world in the way we want.
Joseph and Frank were two life-long Squatchers.
No, that isn’t an insult – that’s a
self-given title for Bigfoot enthusiasts who
are willing to head out into the woods and
search for the legendary Sasquatch first-hand.
While most Squatchers will go their whole
lives without ever encountering one, Joseph
and Frank were about to get lucky – they
just didn’t know what kind of luck.
During a journey through the forests of the
Pacific Northwest, Frank spotted something
moving in the distance: A huge, ape-like creature
with greyish fur and human-like movements.
Frank thought he was finally laying eyes on
the mighty Bigfoot after decades of searching.
What he didn’t know was that he’d just
made a deadly mistake.
He had looked directly at SCP – 1000.
And there would be terrible consequences.
Frank was excited – he’d just achieved
the life goal of any Squatcher.
He tapped Joseph on the shoulder and directed
him to look in the direction of the creature.
Joseph followed Frank’s direction and stared
into the distance.
When his eyes finally came into focus on the
ape-like beast... he froze.
His brain just short-circuited.
One second, he was about to encounter the
Holy Grail of his hobby, and the next, he
was literally brain dead.
Joseph collapsed.
In the distance, the ape-like creature disappeared
back into the woods.
Not that Frank even noticed – he was too
busy trying to wake Joseph but it was no use.
Joseph was gone, and Frank had no idea why.
The headlines read, “BIGFOOT KILLED MY FRIEND.”
Most people either ignored it or laughed it
off.
Just a couple of cranks goofing off in a forest
and one of them had dropped dead.
Who cares?
Well, one organization cared – The SCP Foundation.
Mobile Task Force Zeta-1000, the Foundation’s
specialized SCP – 1000 detail, were alerted
to the reports.
They sprang into action, tracking down and
detaining Frank for questioning.
They process a million loony bigfoot lovers
every year, and usually find nothing, but
the death of Frank’s friend made it all
too clear – they hadn’t encountered a
bigfoot but a real, genuine example of SCP
– 1000.
SCP – 1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous SCPs, but underestimating
the creature is a terrible mistake because
just looking at it gives you a 2% chance of
dropping dead on the spot.
Frank, despite losing his friend, was one
of the lucky ones.
The Foundation debriefed him before administering
amnestics, and making sure that he’d never
venture back to those mysterious forests in
the Pacific Northwest again.
Director Jones, the site director charged
with the management of SCP – 1000 populations,
was given the information on this latest case
of a SCP – 1000-related fatality.
It was a story he’d heard many times before.
For Director Jones, they all seemed to bleed
into one another.
So, what exactly is SCP – 1000?
And how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods?
SCP – 1000 is a whole species of large,
hominid ape-like creatures.
They’re largely nocturnal, but sightings
of the creature during the day aren’t unheard
of.
They’re omnivorous, mostly seeming to consume
plants and insects and their fur is usually
grey, brown, black, red, or occasionally white.
The creatures have large
eyes capable of impressive
vision nestled underneath a
pronounced, Neanderthal-like
brow.
Another defining feature is the ridge of bone
on the forehead, much like that of a gorilla,
that is present in both sexes.
According to Foundation studies, the creatures
exhibit a level of intelligence on par with
that of the common chimpanzee, but nowhere
near that of us humans.
What they lack in intelligence, though, they
more than make up for in size.
The adults can be as large as ten feet tall,
and weigh up to 600 pounds.
Despite their great size and impressive strength,
the creatures are neither
aggressive nor territorial.
In fact, they seem to instinctively avoid
humans, mostly residing deep in the forests
of the American Pacific Northwest and in the
Himalayan Alps.
There have been sightings of SCP – 1000
on every continent, though the Foundation
has taken pains to exterminate all SCP – 1000
populations situated near human population
centres to prevent a potential
disaster, considering
the 2% chance of instantaneous death upon
visual contact.
That brings us to our second question: What
is it that makes these seemingly harmless
creatures so dangerous?
Sadly, for both these unfortunate creatures
and us humans, the danger is beyond the control
of SCP – 1000.
According to Foundation research, SCP – 1000
likely evolved alongside us homo sapiens,
until a tragedy occurred
between ten and fifteen-thousand
years ago.
A mysterious extinction event eliminated the
vast majority of their species, leaving only
one to five percent alive in the aftermath.
What happened?
It’s believed that around this time, SCP
– 1000 contracted what the Foundation refers
to as an “anomalous pseudo-disease.”
Meet SCP-1000-f1, a disease that is passed
along at the genetic level, and is so durable
that it persists in the species to this day.
The tiny fraction of the population that are
immune to its effects manage to survive, but
the majority who aren’t immune die shortly
after birth.
This is why the overall population remains
relatively low to this day.
It’s a disease that only appears to affect
hominids – including humans, chimpanzees,
bonobos, and non-immune instances of SCP-1000.
Any hominid that lays eyes on a carrier of
the disease has a two percent
chance of experiencing
immediate brain death.
While a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening, at least
when compared to some other nightmare inducing
SCPs, the truly scary part is that the percentage
is cumulative.
In other words, the longer one observes a
carrier of SCP-1000-f1, the higher that percentage
rises and the greater your chance of experiencing
an abrupt death.
According to Foundation studies, the percentage
rises by around one percent every twenty minutes.
And the percentage also varies between specimens,
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high death
chance of 90% upon viewing.
This death chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carried
the anomalous pseudo-virus
while alive – though thankfully the risk
doesn’t appear to apply to small fur or
tissue samples.
The Foundation’s true concern actually goes
far beyond SCP – 1000 themselves.
Because of the species’ close relation to
homo sapiens, there’s a worry that SCP-1000-f1
could transmit to humans, causing our own
species to meet a similar fate.
If humans did indeed become
carriers of SCP-1000-f1,
it’s extremely likely that humanity would
undergo an unprecedented extinction event,
with billions across the globe dropping dead
as brain death sets in en masse.
While full extermination of the entire species
has been deemed unlikely, the existential
threat they pose to humanity more than justifies
the occasional culling of SCP – 1000 populations.
That was a lot to take in, right?
First, the creature we thought was Bigfoot
was actually a new species of SCP out in the
wild.
And second, these creatures could end human
life as we know it if they made it into a
population center.
But what you’re about to hear next – a
dark secret only available to people with
Level 3 SCP Foundation clearance – is the
most shocking SCP - 1000 fact of all...
Are you ready?
The true secret of SCP - 1000 is that what
you’ve just heard is a lie.
There is no anomalous pseudo-disease, and
SCP – 1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever.
Who would spread such a thing?
The SCP Foundation, of course.
Strictly speaking, the Foundation has disseminated
two direct lies about the nature of SCP – 1000.
The first is that of the disease, which does
not exist, nor has it ever existed.
The second lie is about
the creature’s intelligence
level – they’re far smarter than the average
chimp.
In fact, they’re every bit as intelligent
as human beings.
These were all lies formulated by Director
Jones and the Foundation, as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth.
The Foundation has been spreading information
that makes the very concept of the Sasquatch
out to be a joke for decades, all to discredit
and further push the very concept of SCP – 1000
into the shadows.
But…why?
The Foundation is no stranger to coming up
with cover stories, but why would they put
intentional lies into their own files to anyone
below a Level 3 clearance?
Well, that all comes down to the horrifying
truth behind the origins of today’s SCP
– 1000 population.
The creatures were first brought to the attention
of the Foundation by outcast members of the
Serpent’s Hand, an organization dedicated
to defying the Foundation’s activities.
These members, known as the Children of the
Sun, told them the secret history of SCP – 1000.
While at first, Foundation personnel like
Director Jones didn’t want to believe what
they were hearing, they soon came to terms
with the horrifying truth.
Humans and SCP – 1000 did evolve alongside
each other, with humans occupying the day
and SCP – 1000 the night.
However, while humans were
still basic hunter-gatherers,
SCP – 1000 were undergoing vast intellectual
and societal development.
They were able to create
tools, weapons, agriculture,
stable settlements, domesticated animals,
and eventually even fully developed cities.
It was like nothing the world had ever seen,
and wouldn’t see for thousands of years
to come.
Their numbers swelled into the tens of billions,
as they created culture and technology hitherto
unimagined – including weapons of devastating
power.
Meanwhile, humanity was pushed to the brink
of destruction by their competitor’s rapid
and seemingly unstoppable growth.
It looked as though the human species had
lost the evolutionary arms race, and would
have to bow out, but according to the Children
of the Sun, a trickster forest god smiled
upon humanity, and gave them the power to
use SCP – 1000’s weapons and technology
against them.
70% of SCP – 1000’s population were wiped
out in a single horrific day, known to the
Children of the Sun as “The Day of the Flowers”
– as every flower supposedly bloomed that
day during the massacre.
Humanity destroyed the entire civilization,
and with the same technology they stole from
these unfortunate creatures, the vengeful
humans drove the apes mad.
Their higher consciousnesses were blocked
out, reducing them back into the states of
mere animals.
Once the massacre was done and everything
that was built had been destroyed, we – the
human race – used the SCP – 1000 weapons
to wipe any memory of the atrocity from our
own minds.
The advanced civilization of SCP – 1000
had been wiped from history.
Humans returned to their plodding path of
evolution, none the wiser.
For thousands of years, all the way up until
today, this time remained a mystery to us.
So again, why did the Foundation lie to us?
What did they have to gain, by convincing
us all that it was dangerous to even look
at these creatures?
Well, as the frequency of sightings and the
attempts at communication increased, people
like Director Jones became aware of a frightening
possibility: What if the pendulum was swinging
back?
What if the apes were regaining their lost
intelligence, and worse, still harboured feelings
of revenge for what we did to their species
thousands of years ago?
Even the mere possibility that they could
do to us what we once did to them is a chance
that the Foundation simply cannot take, and
thus, limiting contact between humans and
SCP - 1000 at all costs is an absolute must.
However, in spite of the Foundation’s fears,
one intercepted message from the apes suggests
that their paranoia may be misplaced.
This message, translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation personnel, reads
simply as follows:
“we forgive you;
given choice for now, not forever;
let us back in.”
It’s enough to make you wonder what species
the Foundation should really be keeping tabs
on here.
After all, when it comes to meting out violence
and death, humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the Foundation
containment cells.
And few examples illustrate that better than
the tragic case of SCP – 1000.